TO THE JUNE TWENTY FOURTH
MEETING OF THE ASSEMBLY NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE -- WITHIN
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM WE ARE
GOING TO BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AND TAKE ANY VOTES
AFTER WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
I ALSO WANT TO ANNOUNCE TO THE
FOLLOWING MEASURES HAVE BEEN
PULLED FROM TODAY'S HEARING.
SB ONE SB FIVE FIVE ONE AND SB.
SIX TWENTY ONE AT OUR FIRST ITEM
UP IS MS REYES 2%.
AJ ARE TEN WAS REYES WHENEVER
YOU ARE READY YOU MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU.
NUMBER. EIGHT OR TEN MAKES A
STATEMENT REGARDING CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP BY
ARTICULATING THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPORT.
OF OUR AUTHORITY TO ENACT
STRICTER AIR POLLUTION STANDARDS
PURSUANT TO THE FEDERAL CLEAN
AIR ACT.
WAIVERS OFFERED UNDER THIS ACT
WHICH HAVE BEEN ISSUED IN
SUPPORT OF OUR BIPARTISAN BASIS
FOR OVER FORTY YEARS ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TO SET A STANDARD.
CURRENTLY FOLLOWED BY OVER
THIRTEEN STATES AND
JURISDICTIONS ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES.
AS MANY OF YOUKNOW THE NATIONAL
HIGHWAY TRAFFIC ADMINISTRATION
AND THE US ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY RECENTLY
PROPOSED.
UNDER THE PRESENT ADMINISTRATION.
THE SAFER AFFORDABLE FUEL
EFFICIENT.
OR AT THE SO CALLED SAFE VEHICLE
ROOM THIS PROPOSAL AIMS TO TAKE
ACTION THAT WOULD WEAKEN THE
ABILITY OF CALIFORNIA TO ENACT
POLICIES.
THAT ADDRESS PUBLIC HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND CONTINUE TO ADDRESS.
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE NATIONAL NATIONAL
MINISTRATIONS.
THE FEDERAL MINISTRATIONS
PROPOSAL AIMS TO AND CURRENT
FUEL ECONOMY TARGETS IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND WITHDRAWAL
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO SET OUR
OWN MORE STRINGENT VEHICLE
STANDARDS.
IT IS CLEAR THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS EMBARKED ON A
POORLY CRAFTED STRATEGY TO ROLL
BACK THE PROGRESS CALIFORNIA'S
MADE ON CLEAN AIR.
DESPITE THE SUPPOSED BENEFITS OF
THE PROPOSAL THE CONSEQUENCES OF
ADOPTING THIS STANDARD HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO BE DETRIMENTAL.
IT IS ESTIMATED AT THAT TAKING
THIS ACTION WILL NOT ONLY
INCREASE OIL CONSUMPTION BY
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND BARRELS PER DAY.
BUT IT IS ESTIMATED TO
POTENTIALLY COST CALIFORNIA
THIRTY SIX BILLION DOLLARS DUE
TO NEGATIVE AFFECTS ON PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY.
GROUPS FROM OF OUR FROM
ENVIRONMENTALISTS TO AUTO MAKERS
HAVE STATED THE CONCERNS.
EARLY THIS EARLIER THIS MONTH
SEVENTEEN MAJOR AUTOMAKERS
INCLUDING BMW FORD GM AND OTHERS
WROTE A LETTER CLAIMING THAT THE
CURRENT STATE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED PLAN
WOULD CAUSE INSTABILITY.
DUE TO THE CURRENT STANDOFF WITH
CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA WAS CLEARLY STATED
THAT WE SUPPORT CLEAN AIR AND
THE NEED TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE AND THE MOST CONCENTRATED
AREA WE CAN'T TODAY.
THAT IS TRANSPORTATION.
SUPPORT OF AG ARE TEN IS A VOTE
FOR SCIENCE AND CONTINUE
DEVELOPMENT OF TECHNOLOGIES TO
PROTECT OUR AIR WITHOUT
COMPROMISING CONSUMER VOICES.
AND CONSUMER CHOICE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION ARE
NIKITA KARATE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND
BILL MCGAVIN WITH THE KELP
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BILL AGAIN WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR STRONG
SUPPORT.
OF THIS MEASURE CALIFORNIA HAS
HAD AND HAS USED THE AUTHORITY
TO SET STANDARDS FOR MOBILE
SOURCES OF AIR POLLUTION SINCE
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND
THAT'S ACCOUNTS FOR A LOT OF THE
SUCCESS WE'VE HAD.
IN REDUCING OUR AIR POLLUTION
UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE THAT
SUCCESS TRANSPORTATION STILL
ACCOUNTS FOR MORE THAN 80% OF
THE AIR POLLUTION THAT WE HAVE
IN CALIFORNIA AND ABOUT HALF OF
OUR GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
MY ORGANIZATION WAS ONE OF THE
SPONSORS OF FRIEND PAVEL EASE
CALIFORNIA CLEAN CARS LAW PASSED
IN TWO THOUSAND TWO WHICH WAS
THE FIRST MEASURE.
IN THE COUNTRY THAT SET
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
STANDARDS FOR MOTOR VEHICLES AND
HAS BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL IT BECAME
A NATIONAL STANDARD.
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
AND ITS THAT NATIONAL AGREEMENT
THAT THIS TRUMP ROLL BACK IS
SEEKING TO DISRUPT AND TO BREAK
AND TO STOP THE THE GREAT
SUCCESS.
THAT WE AND THE WHOLE COUNTRY
NOW THAN HAVING WITH TAIL PIPE
STANDARDS AND THE ROLL BACK IS
SO MISGUIDED THAT IT REALLY IS.
ONLY STANDS TO BENEFIT THE OIL
COMPANIES THAT HAVE SECRETLY
LOBBIED FOR IT SO A CALIFORNIA
AS THE GOVERNOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL -- AND THE LEGISLATURE
HAVE BEEN DOING NEEDS TO
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE THIS
MISGUIDED ROLL BACK AND TO
ASSERT AUTHORITY OVER CLEAN CAR
STANDARDS THANK YOU.
CHEN MEMBERS NIKITA CROWDED WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL I'M ON BEHALF OF ENERGY
SEIZE MORE THAN THREE MILLION
MEMBERS AND ACTIVISTS I'M HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF HR.
TEN AND HE'S HE'S PART OF A
COALITION OF ORGANIZATIONS AND
STATES THAT IS VIGOROUSLY
FIGHTING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S UNJUSTIFIED AND
FAULTY ROLLBACK.
OF COMMONSENSE CLEAN CAR AND
FUEL ECONOMY STANDARDS AND IS
WORKING TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
AUTHORITY OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
CONSUMERS' POCKETBOOKS.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL RELIES ON FAULTY
ASSUMPTIONS THAT LEAD TO A RONI
SWING FLAYED IT COSTS AND BOGUS
SAFETY CLAIMS.
AT THE FIVE YEARS OF RESEARCH
DEMONSTRATING THAT EXISTING
STANDARDS ARE TECHNOLOGICALLY
AND ECONOMICALLY ACHIEVABLE.
DISMANTLING THE STANDARDS IS
INCONSISTENT WITH THE EPA'S
MANDATE UNDER THE CLEAN AIR ACT
TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
WELFARE.
IT ALSO FLIES IN THE FACE OF THE
NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION'S MANDATE DOES
THAT MAXIMUM FEASIBLE FUEL
ECONOMY STANDARDS.
AND PER THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION'S OWN ANALYSIS
THE ROLL BACK PUT THOUSANDS OF
JOBS AT RISK ALL WHILE MAKING
CONSUMERS PAY MORE AT THE PUMP.
INCREASING OUR DEPENDENCE ON OIL
INCREASING POLLUTION FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AND
THREATENING THE WELL BEING OF
CONSUMERS WORKERS AND ALL THOSE
WHO DEPEND ON CLEAN AIR AND A
STABLE CLIMATE.
AJ ARE TEN SENDS A STRONG
MESSAGE TO OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT IT'S THEIR DUTY
TO PROTECT ITS PEOPLE AND NOT
THE SELF SERVING INTERESTS OF
THE OIL INDUSTRY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ANYBODY ELSE
WISHING TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT.
FOR THIS ITEM.
THE COMMISSION ALSO [inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
WELL WE WANT TO HEAR YOU.
HOW MUCH TIME?
WILL BEAR IT WITH THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CHRISTINE SHOEMAKER REGISTERING
SUPPORT FOR THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
ACTION.
DEBORAH SYLVIE REGISTERING WITH
SUPPORT FROM FOSSIL FREE
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THE RESOLUTION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WELL I WILL JUST I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- OUR
CLEAN AIR STANDARDS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN AGREED
SUCCESS BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
TRANSPORTATION IS THE ONE SECTOR
WERE NOT GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. TO MEET OUR CLIMATE
GOALS SO WE NEED TO BE DOING
MORE WORK NOT LESSEN THIS
RESOLUTION I THINK HAS A VERY
GOOD MESSAGE -- TO THE WHITE
HOUSE SO THANK YOU WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
AFTER WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM WILL
BE HAPPY TO TAKE A VOTE ON THE
ITEM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT AUTHOR IS SENATOR WITH
HOUSE SKI WITH SP [inaudible]
ONE SIXTY EIGHT WELCOME SENATOR.
SURE GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
AND LET ME START OFF BY SAYING I
WILL TAKE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS HOUSE WHEN I THINK --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA WHOSE CO
AUTHORING THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
SB ONE SIXTY EIGHT WOULD
ESTABLISH THIS CHEAP CLIMATE
RESILIENCE OFFICER HOUSE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH THROUGHOUT THE OUR
STATE WE HAVE SEEN THE TERRIBLE
EFFECTS OF OUR CHANGING.
CLIMATE AND HOW SEVERELY
DESTROYS OUR COMMUNITIES LOCAL
ECONOMIES AND LEAD TO LOSS OF
LIFE AND PROPERTY.
THE CALIFORNIA IS FOURTH CLIMB
ASSESSMENT.
CLIMATE CHANGE ASSESSMENT POINTS
THE DRIER CONDITIONS IN THE
FUTURE INTERRUPTED BY LARGER
INTENSE STORM BURST -- THAT
INCREASE THE RISK OF FLOODS WE
NEED A WELL COORDINATED STRATEGY
BASED ON THE LATEST SCIENCE
ENABLE OUR STATE TO BE RESILIENT
ENOUGH TO MEET.
THESE ANOTHER INCREDIBLE
CHALLENGES DOWN. TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN I AUTHORED SB. TWO FOUR
SIX WHICH ADDRESSED THE LACK OF
COMPREHENSIVE AND COORDINATED
CLIMATE ADAPTATION PLANNING
BETWEEN THE STATE THE REGION'S
AND LOCAL ENTITIES IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S THE VERTICAL NOT SO MUCH
THE HORIZONTAL -- DISCUSSIONS
THIS BILL TAKES THE NEXT LOGICAL
STEP THE CREATES THE CHEAPER SO
IN OFFICER IN OPR.
AND THE CHEESE CHIEF OFFICER
WOULD BE THE STATE WIDE LEAD TO
MANAGE THE EFFORTS ON ADAPTATION.
THROUGH THE CHIEF RESILIENCE
OFFICER THE ADVISORY COUNCIL AND
STAFF WILL FACILITATE
COORDINATION AMONG STATE
REGIONAL LOCAL AGENCY EFFORTS TO
ADOPT TO THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE
THE BILL ALSO INCLUDES MEMBERS
WITH ADDITIONAL EXPERTISE -- ON
THE ADVISORY COUNCIL STACKERS
ARE FOUR YEAR TERMS -- AND WHEN
YOU ESTABLISH A QUORUM I WOULD
URGE AN AYE VOTE.
I WITNESSES THAT WOULD THIS IS A
POOR PLACE GOOD AFTERNOON BRAIN
AND ALSO SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF US BE ONE
SIXTY A IN RECENT YEARS
CALIFORNIA SEEN AN INCREASE IN
EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS SUCH AS
WILDFIRES DROUGHT AND SEA LEVEL
RISE.
THESE IMPACTS CAUSED BY CLIMATE
CHANGE ONLY EXPECTED TO WORSEN
AS WE'VE GONE PAST THE POINT OF
PREVENTING THE CONSEQUENCES OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
GLOBAL WARMING.
THEREFORE IT IS NECESSARY TO
PREPARE FOR THE INEVITABLE AND
HELP BILL CLIMATE RESILIENCE
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE PHONE
OAKLEY.
AFFORDABLE COMMUNITIES AND
ECOSYSTEMS AND WE BELIEVE SB ONE
SIX EIGHT WOULD YOU JUST THAT BY
INSTALLING A CHIEF CLIMATE
OFFICER IN THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING A RESEARCH THAT RECORD
NAME PLAN. FOR EVENTS JUST LIKE
THIS IN THE FUTURE -- AND WITH
THAT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB ONE
SIX INNER DRIVE A THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
GREAT COOK WITH HIM YOU KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY IN
SUPPORT THE BILL [inaudible]
IN THE IN A SCAN ON BEHALF
MOSQUITO AND VECTOR CONTROL
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA HERE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO CREDIT.
RURAL DETER MY GOSH.
TRY THAT AGAIN GEAR CUT YOU THE
NOT TO RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT.
AARON RODRIGUEZ TO THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
NATALIE NEXT ON BEHALF OF OJ
CONSERVANCY CALIFORNIA CHAO IN
MID PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES OR ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THE BILL.
FACING NONE OUT BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS.
THE COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE.
NONE OKAY -- I'LL JUST SAY THAT
I REALLY RESPECT WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO AND I CAN SUPPORT
THIS TODAY I DO WONDER A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT US.
GETTING INTO THE KIND OF
ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURE BUT
YOU'RE GOING TO YOU'RE NEXT
COMMITTEE WHICH IS ORGANIZATION
A GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION I'M
SURE WE'LL TALK MORE BUT I AGREE
THAT HAVING A COORDINATED --
CLIMATE -- EFFORT DIRECTED BY
ONE PLACE IS PROBABLY A A VERY
GOOD IDEA SO I APPRECIATE BRING
THIS FORWARD WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I'M JUST WINNER TONIGHT
VOTE AND EMOTION PLAN THAT
THAT'S APPROPRIATE.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THANKS.
OUR NEXT AUTHOR HIS SENATOR
HUESO WITH SB.
SIX SIX SEVEN AND WHEN WE CAN
LEAVE THE MICROPHONE OVER HERE
I'M WOULD BE GREAT SO THAT
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE.
TO GET INTO THE CORNER
[inaudible]
AND WHILE -- DO OUR BEST.
TO NOT A PEOPLE TRIP OVER THE
FORD BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT'S WHEN EVERYBODY IN THIS
ROOM THAT THERE IS A CORD IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE ROOM IF YOU COME
UP.
PLEASE TRY TO NOTE THAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR -- AND GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYBODY AND THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT.
SB -- SIX SIX SEVEN I WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN BY.
STATING THAT I I DO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
FOR WORK IN -- WITH MY OFFICE
AND FOR HELPING US -- IMPROVE
THE BILL.
X. SB SIX SIX SEVEN IS A BILL
WHICH SEEKS TO SUPPORT ALL.
OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AS THEY
WORK TOWARDS MEETING ORG ORGANIC
WASTE RECYCLING GOALS.
WITH THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE CAL
RECYCLE TO DEVELOP A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT TO DEVELOP THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY TO MEET
THE STATE'S ORGANICS.
AND RECYCLING REQUIREMENTS
RATHER THAN -- FOCUSING ON
ORGANICS INFRASTRUCTURE ONLY.
IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE CAL
RECYCLED THE TREASURE TO
COORDINATE WITH THE STATE OF
NEVADA OREGON AND WASHINGTON.
ON INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING TO
SUPPORT REGIONAL RECYCLING NEEDS --
TO ALSO SUPPORT DEVELOPMENT OF
INTERSTATE RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE MARKETS
NECESSARY -- TO PLACE THESE.
WE HAVE -- TO INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE HERE -- TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
NICK LAPIS IS WITH THE
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE AND
THE REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA OF COURSE WITH YOUR
PERMISSION MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU WERE GONNA PASTAS FOR
A MOMENT TO ESTABLISH A FARM WE
CAN OF ROLL CALL PLEASE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HERE FRIEDMAN
HERE FLORA FLORA HERE CHAU CHOW
HERE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HERE GARCIA LIMON MATHIS
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY HERE MELENDEZ REFUGEE
STONE.
STONE HERE.
CARE WITNESSES UP TO THREE
MINUTES APIECE THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
ALL RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON JOHN
KENNEDY WITH RC RC -- WE'RE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIXTY SEVEN
BECAUSE IT WILL HELP THE STATE
ACHIEVE ITS AMBITIOUS ORGANICS
RECYCLING MANDATES.
REDUCE POLLUTION AND CREATE JOBS
IN THE STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
REALLY THE BACKBONE FOR MEETING
THE STATE'S SOLID WASTE GOALS --
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE TODAY IS COMPLYING
WITH SB -- THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
THAT REQUIRES THE STATE TO
DIVERT 75% OF ITS ORGANIC WASTE
FROM LANDFILLS BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE SO WE'RE GOING TO SEE A
MASSIVE UP TAKEN THE RECYCLING
OF ORGANIC WASTE -- THAT'S GOING
TO COME AT CONSIDERABLE COST UP
TO THREE BILLION DOLLARS -- IF
NOT MORE SO THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY -- WE
NEED A LOT OF NEW INFRASTRUCTURE
FACILITIES OUT THERE TO PROVIDE
THIS AMOUNT -- OF COMPOST -- AND
DEAL WITH THE LEVELS OF ORGANIC
BUT IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO DEAL WITH -- POTENTIALLY
HUNDRED FACILITIES -- AND THEN
THERE'S A NEW REQUIREMENT THAT
COVER CYCLE IS INCLUDING AND
THEIR DRAFT RAGS THAT WERE
REVISED LAST WEEK -- FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS PROCURE HUNDRED AND
FORTY POUNDS OF COMPOST PER
PERSON -- SO THAT'S GOING TO BE
A PRETTY LARGE UNDERTAKING FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WE DESPERATELY
NEED THE INFRASTRUCTURE OUT
THERE AND WE THINK THIS BILL
WILL HELP US GET THERE.
IT MOVES IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
BY PROVIDING ALTERNATIVE
FINANCING FOR THESE TYPES OF
FACILITIES -- REQUIRING THE
STATE TO DEVELOP -- SOME TYPE OF
INVESTMENT PLAN -- WAR
ASSESSMENT FOR WHAT'S NEEDED FOR
THOSE FACILITIES AND THEN ALSO
REQUIRES CAL RECYCLED TO GO OUT
AND DEVELOP AN INCENTIVE
MECHANISMS TO ACCELERATE PRIVATE
INVESTMENT TO BRING THOSE
FACILITIES AND OPERATIONS SO WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
CAPTION THE CORPUS OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
IN ADDITION TO JOHN COMMENTS ON
THE NEED FOR AGAIN X.
INFRASTRUCTURE I THINK YOU'VE
HEARD OVER AND OVER.
THE SECOND HALF OF THIS BILL IS
TALKING ABOUT RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SPECIFICALLY
PAPER RECYCLING -- IT MIGHT
SOUND FAMILIAR SOME MEMBER
ADMINS LEGISLATION -- SIR LAID
OUT OF SOME MORE VISION OF
DEVELOPING IN STATE MARKETS AND
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THIS
OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE. TO REALLY
BRING HOME RECYCLING BRING HOME
THE BENEFITS.
THIS BILL FALLS IN THE SAME VEIN
AND AND BASICALLY TELLS.
THE CAL OR CYCLE IN THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE WORK TOGETHER
TO FACILITATE.
IN STATE RECYCLING MARKETS FOR
PAPER FOR ORGANIC WASTE FOR
OTHER MATERIALS IT'S A VERY
LOGICAL -- WAY TO MOVE FORWARD
AT THE INFECTION POINT RIGHT
RIGHT NOW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
WISHING TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL.
MICHAEL DEATH WITH THE PRAYER IN
MCKINNEY ON BEHALF OF REPUBLIC
SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
JOSIAH YOUNG ON BEHALF OF THE
BIO ENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
NATALIE MAX ON BEHALF OF SEE ON
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYBODY WISHING TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY SEEING NONE WILL GO BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANYBODY
HAS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SEEING NONE OF MISTER HUESO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU -- WE
HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM THIRTEEN SB SIX SIXTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR HUESO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED EVERY FOR TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN I FRIEDMAN I'VE
FLORA FLORA AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LEMOND.
MATHIS.
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
MELINDA'SMURATSUCHI STONE
[inaudible]
STONE AYE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU BELIEVE THE
ROLE OF SENATOR ALLEN.
YOUR NEXT WITH SB.
FORTY THREE THANK YOU SO MUCH
AROUND HERE MEMBERS.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL AND LIKE TO
THINK THEM ALSO FOR THE DETAILED
ANALYSIS.
HI THIS BILL REQUIRES THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO SUBMIT A
REPORT.
ON THE FEAST ON THE FEASIBILITY
OF PRACTICALITY OF CALCULATING.
CARBON INTENSITY OF RETAIL
PRODUCTS SUBJECT TO THE SALES
AND USE TAX IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT FROM A
PROGRAM SUCH AS THE CAP AND
TRADE SYSTEM PLAY AN INTEGRAL
ROLE IN REDUCING EMISSIONS IN
CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER THE WIDE ARRAY OF
FACTORS INFLUENCING CONSUMER
PRICES OFTEN MASKS THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT.
OF THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM AND
CONSUMERS ARE UNABLE TO SAVE
MONEY BY CHOOSING.
I CLIMATE FRIENDLY ALTERNATIVE
SO THIS IS THIS IS A STUDY BILL --
THE NO QUESTION ABOUT IT BUT IT
DID DID STUDIES AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE WHICH IS -- LOOKING AT ARE
THE POSSIBILITY OF OF LITERALLY
DOING AWAY WITH OUR SALES AND
USE TAX ALTOGETHER.
AND REPLACING IT WITH A REVENUE
NEUTRAL CARBON PRICING MECHANISM
BASED ON THE PRODUCTS CARBON
INTENSITY.
SO THAT'S THE THAT'S WHAT WE BE
LOOKING AT THE POSSIBILITY OF
DOING -- BASED ON ON ON ALL THE
DATA THAT WOULD THAT THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD COULD PULL
TOGETHER WE'VE BEEN HAVING VERY
PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSIONS.
WITH STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
THOSE IN OPPOSITION AND TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS AYE I DO
BELIEVE WE'RE VERY CLOSE TO
REACHING CONSENSUS ON LANGUAGE --
I HAVE WITH ME HERE TODAY MYSELF
A SERAPH FROM THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY ALSO I CHRISTY
SHOEMAKER FROM FOSSEL FREE
CALIFORNIA AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
HERE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF SB.
FORTY THREE WITNESSES.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WE
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP OF
SENATOR ALLEN BOTH FOR THE
CLIMATE AND ENVIRONMENT.
SB FORTY THREE IS A STUDY BILL
WILL PROVIDE THE STATE WITH
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
I CAN INFORM DISCUSSIONS ON HOW
CALIFORNIA MIGHT REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS EVEN
FURTHER.
AT THIS POINT WE NEED TO EXPLORE
ALL OPPORTUNITIES.
SO WE CAN UNDERSTAND BETTER HOW
WE CAN ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE
MOST EFFECTIVELY AND QUICKLY AND
THE SHOULD INCLUDE EXAMINING THE
SALES AND USE TAX IS A POTENTIAL
MECHANISM.
LAST FALL THE INTERGOVERNMENTAL
PANEL ON CLIMATE CHANGE ISSUED A
REPORT YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH
THIS WHERE HIGHLIGHTS A GLOBAL
URGENCY OF BECOMING CARBON
NEUTRAL IF NOT CARBON NEGATIVE
BY MID CENTURY.
IN ORDER TO KEEP OVERALL
TEMPERATURES FROM RISING NO MORE
THAN ONE POINT FIVE DEGREES
CELSIUS THIS IS COMPARED TO PRE
INDUSTRIAL LEVELS.
THIS REPORT FOLLOWS ON THE HEELS
OF THE PARIS AGREEMENT TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN FOR COUNTRIES
COMMITTED TO KEEP TEMPERATURE
INCREASES TO WELL BELOW TWO
DEGREES.
CELSIUS TO AVOID THE MOST
CATASTROPHIC IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
CALIFORNIA IS A LEADER ON THE
CLIMATE FRONT.
WE ALSO NEED TO DO MORE IF YOU
WANT TO DO OUR PART AND HELP.
ME TO PARIS COMMITMENTS AND
FOLLOW THE IPCC REPORT GUIDANCE.
WE SEE SENATE BILL FORTY THREE
AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO UNDERSTAND
THE VIABILITY INEFFECTIVENESS OF
ANOTHER TOOL.
THIS TIME FOCUS ON CONSUMERS.
THAT WAS A TO HELP US IN THIS
EFFORT AND REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA AND
POTENTIALLY OUTSIDE OF ITS
BORDERS.
YOU CAN COMPLEMENT.
THE PROGRAMS THAT WE'VE ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED TO HELP REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS SO WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
SO WE CAN UNDERSTAND WHETHER
CHANGE THE SALES AND USE TAX
COULD ALSO BE A PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
SO CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHRISTINE
SHOEMAKER.
I'M A MEMBER OF PHILOSOPHY
CALIFORNIA I'M A RETIRED PLAN
LIKE YOUR BIOLOGIST IMMINENT
BOARD MEMBER OF FOSSIL FREE.
PUZZLE FOR CALIFORNIA'S A
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION WITH OVER
SEVEN THOUSAND ONLINE SUPPORTERS
AND OUR MISSION IS TO WORK TO
AND FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR
CLIMATE DAMGING FOSSIL FUELS.
AND PROMOTED JUST TRANSITION TO
A LOW CARBON ECONOMY.
THIS BILL FITS WITH OUR MISSION.
THE PROBLEM CLIMATE CHANGE WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT THAT ARE MADE PUBLIC
TALK TO TALK ABOUT THAT IT'S AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT.
WE NEED A FAST DRAW DOWN IN A
MULTI PRONGED APPROACH.
IF WE'RE GOING TO GET TO A LOW
CARBON ECONOMY ONE THAT THE
THINGS WE NEED TO DO IS
UNDERSTAND WHERE IN THE ECONOMY
THE CARBON IS.
AND THAT'S FOR CARBON INTENSITY
TO TERMINATION COMES IN AND IF
WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT IT NEEDS
TO BE STANDARDIZED CONSISTENT
AND ACCURATE.
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY EASY TO DO
TO DETERMINE THAT BUT THERE ARE
MECHANISMS OUT THERE.
AND CARP HAS BASICALLY DONE THIS
FOR FUELS IN THE LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD.
CARB STUDYING THE FEASIBILITY OF
WHETHER WE COULD LOOK AT THE
CARBON INTENSITY OF EVERYTHING
IS SUBJECT TO THE SALES AND USE
TAX WOULD BE REALLY USEFUL.
PASSING THIS BILL WITH AN
IMPORTANT MESSAGE TO
MANUFACTURERS AND CONSUMERS
ALIKE.
THE CALIFORNIA WANTS WHAT'S MADE
AND SOLD IN CALIFORNIA TO BE LOW
IN CARBON AND ALSO WHAT'S
BONDING IN CALIFORNIA TO BE LOW
IN CARBON.
IT IS A BROAD MESSAGE TO THE
PUBLIC ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
CONSIDERING CARBON.
IN ALL THAT YOU DO AND BY.
SO WE URGEAN AYE VOTE BECAUSE
WE NEED TO MEASURE CARBON LIKE
OUR PLAN IT DEPENDS ON IT.
BECAUSE INDEED TO HAVE A LIVABLE
PLANET IT DOES.
SO WE WANT TO THANK SENATOR
ALLEN FOR INTRODUCING THE BILL
AND ASKING US TO SPEAK AND FOR
THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF AN
ALLOWING US TO HAVE TESTIMONY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL [inaudible]
OKAY.
JANET CARDS.
FOR BUT OF FORTY THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
TINA GAL YOUR RUTH REZO CENTER
WELL BREAKER FOR THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OKAY THANK YOU AS OR ANYBODY
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LEAH SO WITH OUR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE I WANT TO FIRST START
OUT BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR HELP ON ALICE'S STAND
FOR THE SENATOR'S OFFICE AND HIS
STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK.
I'M TROUBLED HOUSES WE HAD HOPED
THAT WE HAD GOTTEN TO A NEUTRAL
POSITION IN THE LAST HOUSE --
LITTLE BIT CHANGES HERE -- BUT
WE DO WE ARE OPTIMISTIC THAT WE
CAN REACH AGREEMENT ON A COUPLE
OF REMAINING ISSUES -- PRIMARILY
AROUND ENSURING THAT THE STUDY
EVALUATES AND TAKES INTO
CONSIDERATION EXISTING CARBON
MISSION PROGRAMS IN EVALUATING
CARBON INTENSITY AND ENTERING
SOME DEFINITIONAL CHANGES SO WE
ARE OPTIMISTIC THAT -- WITH THE
ADOPTION OF ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE
THAT THE SENATORS INCLUDING WE
WILL GO TO INITIAL POSITION SO
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS SENATOR.
ALLEN AND HIS STAFF FOR THE WORK
ON THE BILL SO FAR MANY MISTRAL
COOK I REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION.
WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO SB -- FORTY
THREE HOWEVER WE ARE REVIEWING A
MOMENT AS THEY COME THROUGH --
AND WE ARE HOPEFUL.
THAT WE CAN REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION AT SOME POINT -- OR
OPPOSITION HERE IS ROOTED IN THE
FACT THAT WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
OTHER STUDIES THAT ARE GOING TO
BE CONDUCTED THAT WILL BRING
CALIFORNIA TO A CARBON NEUTRAL
ECONOMY -- BY TWO OR ARE
INTENDED TO BRING CALIFORNIA TO
A CARBON NEUTRAL ECONOMY.
BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT SUCH
STUDIES IN ARE PRECLUDED FROM
DOING A CARBON TAX -- BUT WHAT
WE ARE ASSERTING THAT WE DON'T
NEED TO FORCE A CARBON TAX STUDY
IF THEY'RE EQUALLY EFFECTIVE
ALTERNATIVES TO ACHIEVE THE SAME
POLICY GOAL.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
MANUFACTURES HAVING CONTINUE TO
BE STRONG PARTNERS IN REDUCING
CARBON EMISSIONS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE BEEN AT THE
TABLE FOR CAP AND TRADE AND WE
CONTINUE TO BE LEADERS IN
CREATING ADOPTING THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT ALLOWS FOR CLEANER.
AND GREENER PRODUCTION.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
STILL OPPOSE BUT WE ARE HOPING
TO GETTING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
WISHING TO VOICE OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
OKAY SEEING NOBODY ELSE I'LL
TAKE THE BILL NOW THE DISCUSSION
TO THE DYESS IF THERE IS ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM.
ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AS A MEMBER OF THE PARTY THANK
YOU AYE AYES I SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE I I JUST HAVE A QUESTION
FOR THE SENATOR SO.
THE NOTION OF THIS IS A STUDY
AND LOOKING AT THE CARBON TAX AS
A POTENTIAL MODEL.
YOU MENTIONED THAT IS TO BE
REVENUE NEUTRAL.
IT LOOKING AT THE CURRENT RATE
FOR OUR SALES AND USE TAX I
GUESS TWO THINGS.
ONE IT'S REVENUE SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME BUT AS THINGS CHANGE WITH
THAT TECHNOLOGY.
IT COULD FLUCTUATE AND HOW HOW
THAT IMPACTS YOU KNOW EXISTING
MONEY GOING. TO OUR STATE FOR
SALES AND USE TAXES THAT PAY FOR
SCHOOLS AND ROADS IN.
PUBLIC SERVICES AND SO FORTH
YEAH THE I MEAN THIS IS THAT IS
ACTUALLY SOMETHING THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE TO LOOK AT AS PART OF
THE STUDY RIGHT IN THE THE ONE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
WOULDN'T BE A ANY ANY DECREASE.
TO PUBLIC REVENUES BOB WHAT WE
DO WHEN WE CALL IT NEVER USUALLY
TWENTY MAKE SURE THAT THIS IT'S
CLEAR THAT WE'RE NOT.
WE'RE NOT USING THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE TAXES ON
THAT ON THE POPULATION -- BUT
BUT THAT WOULD THAT'S IT THAT'S
SOMETHING WE LOOK AT AND AND THE
YEAH THAT THE FOLKS SETTING IS
PART OF THAT THE STUDY.
WOULD HAVE TO TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE WOULDN'T BE ANY NET LOSS
IN PUBLIC REVENUES SO IF IT IS
REVENUE NEUTRAL AND THERE'S NO
[inaudible]
INCREASED.
TO PAY FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
PROGRAMS LIKE WE DO WITH CAP AND
TRADE.
OR TO CHANGE BEHAVIOR THEN HOW
DOES THAT IMPACT.
THE ENTITIES OUT THERE WHO
YOU'RE SEEKING TO TO MAKE A
CHANGE.
THERE COULD BE -- THEN WHEN ONE
POSSIBILITY WOULD BE -- KIND OF
A MECHANISM WHERE YOU WOULD
TWEAK IT OVER TIME WHERE YOU
COULD INCREASE -- THE TAX TO A
CERTAIN PRODUCT IF THERE WAS IT
IF THERE WAS A YOU KNOW A
DECREASE TO PUBLIC REVENUE
ASSOCIATED WITH -- YOU KNOW WITH
WITH THE CHANGE SO THAT WOULD BE
ONE WAY BUT YOU HAVE TO CREATE
SOME SORT OF MECHANISM TO MAKE
SURE THERE WASN'T A LOT BUT IT'S
IDEA TO HAVE A PRODUCT CHANGE
ITS STRUCTURE ITS IMPACT IS THAT.
IS THAT KIND OF WHAT THE GOAL IS
LIKE WE I THINK THE GOAL LIKE
WITH CAP AND TRADE IS.
TO IS TO LOOK AT THE POSSIBILITY
OF WHAT.
OF OF MAKING SURE THAT -- THAT
THAT WE DO A BETTER JOB OF
BUILDING IN THE THE TRUE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH.
CERTAIN TYPES OF PRODUCTS -- AND
IT OVER TIME WE COULD YOU KNOW
AYE AYES BEHAVIORS SHIFT.
WE WOULD HAVE.
TO AS YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENED
TRADE RIGHT IN THAT THEY DID
THEY GETS.
YOU KNOW WE WE WE WE GET UP THE
INTO WE KEPT THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT OF THE
PRODUCT -- BUT YOU WITH THE BILL
THESE IS OPEN ENDED SO AS TO
ALLOW FOR SOME.
TAX EXPERTS TO REALLY SPEND SOME
TIME DIGGING INTO THE
POSSIBILITIES AND COME UP WITH A
MECHANISM THAT -- THAT THEY THAT
THEY THINK WOULD BE FAIR AND AND
THAT WOULD ADDRESS.
THIS ISSUE OVER OF POTENTIAL
REVENUE LOSS.
AND BEHAVIORAL CHANGE.
SO WHAT WE WE DON'T WE ARE WE'RE
NOT DELINEATING A PARTICULAR
PATH HERE -- BUT WERE CONVENING
EXPERTS.
TO YOU KNOW.
TO TO YOU KNOW TO TO TO TO LOOK
AT I HAVE A WHAT YOU KNOW IT IT
IT IT IT BUT BURKE WHICH TO WEAR
DIFFERENT POSSIBILITIES ME ME ME
LEAD US.
I'M NOT TRYING TO BE.
NO BIG HERE BUT WE WE REALLY DO
WANT TO LEAVE IT OPEN ENDED SO
THAT EXPERTS CAN SPEND SOME TIME
REALLY GRAPPLING WITH.
WITH THESE THINGS OKAY NOT WHAT
WE NOW I WILL SAY.
THE BECAUSE OF THE CHANGES THAT
ARE MADE AND IT WILL.
WHAT WE'RE REALLY NOT FOCUSING
ON TRYING TO SEE IF THERE'S SOME
WAY? TO TO ASSESS THE CARBON
INTENSITY IN A PRODUCT THAT'S
REALLY WHAT WE'VE GONE WITH OUR
DISCUSSIONS -- SO WE'RE WE'RE
WE'VE WE'VE MOVED TO WET MY MY
ORIGINAL VISION WAS THIS.
KIND OF THOUGHT WHAT IF WE WERE
JUST LITERALLY REPLACE THE THE
SALES AND USE TAX TO THE REVENUE
NEUTRAL CARBON TAX.
ON THIS COULD HELP US MOVE IN
THAT DIRECTION BUT WHERE THE
BILL IS NOW WITH THE AMENDMENTS
AND I REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE
WORK WE'VE DONE WITH OPPOSITION --
WE'RE NOW IN A PLACE WHERE WHERE
WHERE WORLD JUST LASKIN REALLY
LOOKING AT HOW WE MIGHT GO ABOUT
PRICING CARBON INTENSITY
ASSOCIATED WITH CONSUMER
PRODUCTS.
AND SO.
IT'S ALL THE QUESTIONS YOU'RE
ASKING ARE ARE OBSOLETE ON POINT
THERE IS A LITTLE PREMATURE
GIVEN WHERE THE BILL IS IN GIVEN --%
CAM HOW IT'S MOVING RIGHT NOW
BUT I I THINK THAT THE
DISCUSSION WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
HAVE.
IF WE DECIDE THAT THERE REALLY
IS A A MECHANISM FOR FOR
PROPERLY PRICING CARBON
INTENSITY IF WE WANT TO ADOPT
THIS MODEL.
HAS A STATE ON THE LINE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER ON I
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS LONG LINE OF
OF THAT SO MEMBER MCCARTY JUST
IN.
JUST AND LIKE YOU KNOW IS THE
GRAND SCHEME TO PUT IT HARD TO
CAP AND TRADE IS IT WOULD BE A
WHOLE SEPARATE SYSTEM DO WE KNOW --
AND THEN I GUESS THE THE IDEA OF
MARKET BASED SYSTEMS LIKE THAT I
MEAN.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH DECREASED
WE'VE SEEN WE'RE CHARGING PEOPLE
TO TO POLLUTE BUT THAT DOESN'T
ALWAYS CHANGE BEHAVIOR.
IF YOU CAN AFFORD THE PRICE OF A
POLLUTION -- BUT I GUESS MY
QUESTION LIKE TO ASK THE DATE IS --
WHAT CERTAIN TYPES OF PRODUCTS
IT WAS IT HOW EXPENSIVE ARE THE
TYPES OF PRODUCTS THAT YOU CAN
BE -- UNDER CONSIDERATION IN
THIS OR IS AT ALL IS THAT ALL
LEFT TO TO THE AGENCY DECIDE.
ARE.
LARGELY IT'S IT'S LESS EASY TO
SIDE AND WHERE WE ARE -- AND
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE KEEPING AN
OPEN AND ON PURPOSE FOR THAT FOR
YOU BECAUSE WE WANT TO GIVE THEM
THE FLEXIBILITY -- YOU KNOW. TO
TO TO BE ABLE.
TO TO YES TO TO DO THIS WORK
RIGHT AT ME THE OTHER DAY -- THE
THE ECONOMY WILL CHANGE PRODUCTS
WILL CHANGE THINGS CONTINUE TO
EVOLVE -- WE WE WE WANTED TO
PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY TO THEM.
IS IT JUST JUST THINGS THAT ARE
PROCESS BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
TALKING OF FOOD ITEMS MIGHT BE
TALK RED APPLE RIGHT NO TALKING
ABOUT -- WE'RE WE'RE TENER ARE
YOU TALKING ABOUT A WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING AT DISPOSABLE
DIAPER BUT ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING.
YOUR THAT ANYTHING IN ANYTHING
IT'S SUBJECT TO THE SALES TAX
AYE BUT I GUESS -- IN THE END OF
THE DAY I KNOW THAT THIS IS A
POTENTIALLY VERY COMPLICATED
THING AND WHAT I'VE SAID OVER
AND OVER AGAIN ON THE SENATE
SIDE.
MY AS A BILL IS MOVING THROUGH
IS IT IT MAY VERY WELL BE THAT
WE LOVE THE CONCEPT OF DOING
THIS IT ON THE LINE.
BUT THAT THE FEASIBILITY IS JUST
SO OUT OF CONTROL THAT SO
DIFFICULT TO PROPERLY PRICE
THESE THINGS THAT JUST FROM A
PRACTICALITY PERSPECTIVE IT IS
NOT WORTH DOING.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY WERE YEAH WE'RE CONSIDERING
THE IDEA WE'RE LOOKING INTO A
LITTLE BIT.
AND IF IF IT BUT IT BUT YOU DO
UFC RIGHT I MEAN THESE ISSUES
HAVE COME UP AS WE AS WE'VE BEEN
MOVING ALONG AND THEY MAY PROVE
THIS WAY TOO DIFFICULT THE JUST
THE A MAY BE A GREAT IDEA BUT
DOES NOT A GOOD THING. TO DO
FROM A FROM OF IMPLEMENTATION
PERSPECTIVE.
AND IF THAT'S THE CASE I SILLY
WHEN NOT IN USE IN PURSUING IT
ANY FURTHER BUT I DO WANT TO
GIVE IT A LOOK I THINK.
WE OUGHT TO GET SOME EXPERTS TO
REALLY SPEND SOME TIME LOOKING
AT THIS BECAUSE RIGHT NOW -- BUT
WE KNOW WE WE HAVE ENORMOUS
PROBLEMS AFTER DRESSERS AND YOU
THE CAPITATE SYSTEM IS.
MUCH SMALLER THAN THE SALES TAX.
SYSTEM.
NOW WE CAN REALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE HERE IF WE DO IT
RIGHT BUT IF IT PROVES THAT THAT
IS JUST THE INVISIBLE IT'S NOT
WORTH PURSUING.
IT IS THE CONCEPT THEN THAT IT
WOULD REPLACE SALES TAX.
THAT WAS THE ORIGINAL IDEA YES
THAT'S IDEA. TO REPLACE IT AND
IF YOU DO YOU DO YOU DO YOU
REPLACE IT WITH THE WITH THE
REVENUE NEUTRAL -- PRICING TAX
BASED ON CARBON INTENSITY BUT AS
I SAY RIGHT NOW IT'S ONLY.
ALL WE'RE DOING NOW IS IS
GETTING THEM TO LOOK AT CARBON A
DUNE ASSESSMENT OF CARBON
INTENSITY.
AND IT WOULD BE THE FIRST STEP
TOWARD TOWARD YUP TOWARD MOVING
TOWARDS AND I GUESS IT IS
SOMETHING WE REALLY TO SAY WE
WANT TO DO.
IT THEN TOOK THEN IF I CAN JUST
ASK BECAUSE WE'RE THERE'S
THERE'S ALSO BEEN ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT MOVING FROM
A SALES TAX MODEL TO A SERVICE
TAX MODEL BECAUSE SO MUCH MORE
OF OUR ECONOMY IS BASED ON THE
SERVICE INDUSTRY NOW.
SO WITH THAT ALSO THEN APPLIED.
TO SERVICES RENDERED.
WE'RE LOOK THIS IS THIS IS THIS
IS THIS IS -- RESPONSE TO THE
CURRENT SALES TAX SYSTEM SO WE
WOULD HAVE TO CROSS THAT BRIDGE
WHEN WE GOT THERE IF THAT WAS
WHERE THE LEGISLATURE WAS WAS
GOING.
AS I AY ALL WE'REDOING WITH
THIS IS IS STUDYING AN
ASSESSMENT -- A COULD YOU
WHATEVER DATA COMES OUT OF THAT
ASSESSMENT COULD THEN BE FIT
INTO WHATEVER PLAN WE HAVE WITH
REGARDS TO MOVING FORWARD WITH A
SALES OR SERVICES TAX SYSTEM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
OKAY HOW TO SAY FOR MY PART IT'S
A BIG BOLD IDEA BUT WE HAVE A
MAJOR CRISIS AND SO.
I WOULD WANT TO TAKE ANY BIG
BOLD IDEAS OFF THE TABLE BEFORE
WE'VE EVEN GIVEN THEM
CONSIDERATIONS ALL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY -- WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YEAH I
JUST APPRECIATE -- PURSUE THE
GOOD QUESTIONS THEY'RE ALL GREAT
I MEAN I I YOU KNOW AND I I KNEW
THAT I DON'T HAVE AS SPECIFIC
ANSWERS IN THAT THERE'S A REASON
FOR THAT RIGHT THE BILL IS IS A
NECESSITY TO STUDY AND WE'RE
WE'RE FOR HOW.
TO GET.
GET ALL THESE ISSUES ANSWERED
BUT I I DO WANT TO PERSONALLY
THANK THE SUPPORTERS AND I ALSO
WANT TO THANK -- THE FOLKS IN
OPPOSITION YOU'VE BEEN WORKING
REALLY CLOSELY WITH OUR STAFF
AND OUR OFFICE I I'M I'VE I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF
THE CHAMBER THAT THERE.
ARE VERY ACHINGLY CLOSE TO BEING
NEUTRAL -- THAT'S THAT'S
FANTASTIC AND WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH HIM CA AND
OTHERS TO TO TO GET THIS TO A
PLACE WHERE WE CAN -- WE CAN ALL
FEEL GOOD ABOUT JUST LEARNING A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE
CURRENT SYSTEM WHERE WHERE WE
MIGHT WANT TO GO.
YOU KNOW WAY MOVING INTO THE
FUTURE -- SO WITH THAT I I THINK
IT MERITS ARE OUR EXPLORATION
OUR OUR ASSESSMENT OR STUDY AND
I RESPECT FOR US IN A VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OUR LOCAL POLICE.
SORRY WE HAVE A MOTION.
THE REMOTE SECOND NOW WITH US
FOR A LOOK.
ITEM THREE SB FORTY THREE BY
SENATOR ALLEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFER TO REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA
AYE LIMóN.
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY
AYE MELENDEZ BROUGHT TO G..
STONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
OUR NEXT AUTHOR IS SENATOR
SKINNER WITH SB.
FORTY NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS -- SB.
FORTY NINE WOULD OPEN THE DOOR
FOR OUR FOR ALL OF US TO BE ABLE
TO UTILIZE TECHNOLOGICAL
INNOVATIONS WHICH MANY OF US
HAVE RIGHT ON OUR PHONE OR ON
OUR SMART METER AT HOME OR ON
THE THERMOSTAT IN OUR HOUSE.
OR ANY NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS --
SO WE NOTE NOW THAT THERE'S LOTS
OF APPLIANCES ON THE MARKET THAT
ARE CALLED SMART APPLIANCES THAT
ALLOW YOU TO BE HOOKED UP ON
YOUR PHONE. TO BE ABLE TO TURN
THEM ON AND OFF REMOTELY TO BE
ABLE TO CHANGE SETTINGS ALL OF
THAT.
BUT RIGHT NOW.
WE BECAUSE OF THE STATUTE
EXISTING STATUTE FOR THE ENERGY
COMMISSION IT ENABLES ENERGY
COMMISSION ONLY TO SET APPOINT
STANDARDS FOR ENERGY EFFICIENCY.
AND THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY IS
RESTRICTED TO THAT WHICH IS COST
EFFECTIVE IN THE COST EFFECTIVE
IS A NARROW DEFINITION.
AND THE CREW IT MUST BE ONLY
THOSE THINGS THAT DIRECTLY
REDUCE THE INDIVIDUAL RATE
PAYERS COST.
NOW WE KNOW THAT WITH AS WE ARE
EMBARKING ON GETTING MORE AND
MORE RENEWABLE ENERGY IN OUR
CURRENT GRID 50% AND THEN A 100%.
IT IS VERY OPTIMAL FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO USE THAT RENEWABLE
ENERGY WHEN IT IS GENERATED AND
RENEWABLE ENERGY IS NOT
NECESSARILY GENERATED.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN SO IF WE CAN
MANAGE OUR DEMANDS WHICH THESE.
APPLICATIONS AND SMART
APPLIANCES WOULD ALLOW US. TO TO
UTILIZE THAT ENERGY MAXIMIZE IT
WHEN IT'S BEING GENERATED.
WE WILL GET FAR MORE BANG FOR
OUR BACK WE WILL HAVE PERHAPS
NEED.
TO BUILD LESS POWER PLANTS EVEN
RENEWABLE ONCE AND FOR SURE WE
WOULD REDUCE OUR RELIANCE ON HER
PLANTS WHICH ARE STILL PRIMARILY.
POWERED BY NATURAL GAS SO
BASICALLY SB FORTY NINE WOULD
JUST ALLOW THE ENERGY COMMISSION
TO BE ABLE TO SET STANDARDS SO
THE FIRST SMART APPLIANCES
ADDITIONALLY.
SO THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO REAP
THE BENEFITS OF THOSE SMART
APPLIANCES FOR AN ENERGY DEMAND
TO PURPOSE.
AND I HAVE SOME WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT FROM HOME CONNECT AND
FROM THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND
DEMAND RESPONSE COUNCIL OKAY
GREAT THANK GAIL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LILLIAN MARVIS I'M A GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS MANAGER -- FOR CONNECTS --
CAN ACT AS A RESIDENTIAL DEMAND
RESPONSE SOFTWARE COMPANY BASED
OUT OF SAN FRANCISCO AND I'M
HERE TODAY TO SHARE THAT WE
SUPPORT SB.
FORTY NINE JUST AS SENATOR
SKINNER'S HAND AS MORE
RENEWABLES COME ONLINE IS
CALIFORNIA STRIVES TO MEET IT SB
ONE HUNDRED GOALS.
IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE THAT THE DEMAND OF
ELECTRICITY MATCHES WHEN NOT
SUPPLY IS CLEAN AND
PREDOMINATELY GENERATED BY
RENEWABLE ENERGY.
WHAT SB FORTY NINE DOES IS TAKE
ANY HOUSEHOLD APPLIANCE AND
MAKES ACT DEVICE SMARTER AND
GREAT CONNECTED SO THAT IT CAN
RESPOND IN REAL TIME TO THE
CONDITIONS ON THE GRAD?
THOSE CONDITIONS AREN'T.
SHEREEN WHEN THERE'S HIGH
PROPORTION OF RENEWABLES BUT IT
ALSO SHARES WHEN PRICES ARE LOW
SO THAT CONSUMERS ARE USING
ELECTRICITY WHEN IT'S CHEAP BEST.
WHERE OWN CONNECT IS MOST
EXCITED ABOUT SB FORTY NINE IS
THAT IT TAKES ANY RESIDENTIAL
UTILITY CUSTOMER?
AND HELPS THEM BE A PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY
TRANSITION.
OUR HOMES WITH THE SMART DEVICES
CAN HELP INTEGRATE RENEWABLES
ONTO THE GRAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH STRONGLY URGE
AN AYE VOTE I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THEIR ANIMAL --
REPRESENTING THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL AS YOU KNOW AND SENATOR
ALREADY SAID.
CALIFORNIA HAS AN ABUNDANCE OF
ENERGY THE QUESTION IS REALLY
AND HOW THAT ENERGY EBBS AND
FLOWS THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
SO BASICALLY WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS OBVIOUSLY MAXIMIZE THE
POTENTIAL FOR USING CONSUMER
SIDE -- DEMAND MANAGEMENT
TECHNOLOGIES TO HELP RENEWABLES
AND ENERGY BASICALLY INTEGRATE
BETTER INTO THE GRID -- AND SO
WE APPRECIATE THAT VERY VERY
MUCH SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU IS ANYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
THANK YOU TO CROWDED WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
BRENT AND ALSO SIERRA CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT.
JAY ZIEGLER THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
VERY GOOD WELL NOW GO UP TO THE
DICE AND SEE IF THERE'S ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN FOR THE
SAKE OF ASKING A QUESTION -- CAN
YOU TALK ABOUT THE THE SOCIAL
COST OF THE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS HOW IS A BALLOT UNDER
THE CDC'S ANALYSIS WHEN WE TRY
TO FIGURE OUT.
WHAT CALIFORNIANS CAN ACTUALLY
AFFORD?
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION -- SO THERE'S LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL.
SEE I CAN GO TO THE EXACT PAGE.
THE BASICALLY ALLOWS THE
COMMISSION TO CONSIDER.
THE SOCIAL COST OF GREENHOUSE
GASES.
BUT IT FIRST HAS TO MAKE A
FINDING.
THAT THE THE APPLIANCE STANDARDS
THAT CREATE THIS FLEXIBLE DEMAND
DO NOT UNREASONABLY OR
UNNECESSARILY IMPACT.
THE THE COST EFFECTIVENESS
ASPECT THAT'S THE FIRST AND
FOREMOST THE EXISTING STATUTE OF
THE COMMISSION OR ALSO THE
ABILITY OF I INDIVIDUAL REPAIRS
TO BUY THESE COMPLIANT
APPLIANCES.
SO.
THE WAY WE'VE STRUCTURED THE
BILL IS THAT THAT PROVISION
WOULD NOT SUPERSEDE THE EXISTING
COST EFFECTIVENESS.
NOW THERE IS AN ISSUE ABOUT WHAT
IS MEANT BY SOCIAL COSTS WE ARE
WORKING RIGHT NOW.
WITH THE SIMPLY ENERGY TO COME
UP THE DEFINITION AND WE ARE.
OBVIOUSLY SOCIAL COST COULD MEAN
A LOT OF THINGS BUT WHAT WE ARE
INTERESTED IN.
IS HAVING IT BE COSTS TO
RATEPAYERS IT DOESN'T RIGHT NOW
THE STATUTE IS MORE SPECIFIC TO
AN INDIVIDUAL RATE PAYER.
BUT WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THINGS
SUCH AS AVOIDED TRANSMISSION OR
AVOIDED NEW INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE
NEW GENERATION THOSE ARE COSTS
THAT WOULD BENEFIT ALL RATE
PAYERS.
SO THE TYPE OF DEFINITION WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS STILL WITH IN THAT
RATE PAYER SPACE VERSUS YOU KNOW --
AN UNLIMITED [inaudible]
THE QUESTION.
WHAT IS ONE OF THE THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD --
ABOUT TWELVE YEARS AGO WHEN I
WAS ON THE GLENDALE CITY COUNCIL --
I VOTED TO ALLOCATE ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS -- FROM
THE CITY IN THE UTILITY TO MAKE
GLENDALE THE FIRST CITY IN
CALIFORNIA TO BE COMPLETELY
SMART METER ON THE WATER AND THE
POWER SIGNED.
AND ONE OF THE PROMISES THAT WAS
MADE AT THE TIME FROM THE
UTILITY FOR THE INVESTMENT WAS
THAT WE BECAUSE SO MANY PEOPLE
HAVE SMART APPLIANCES.
THAT THE RATE PAYERS EVEN THOUGH
THERE WAS THIS INITIAL -- ACOSTA
THE CITY WOULD HAVE TO BEAR IN
THE END WE WOULD SAVE MONEY
BECAUSE WE BE ABLE TO DEMAND
MANAGEMENT PEOPLE COULD.
TELL THEIR APPLIANCES TO RUN
WHEN UP POWER WAS CHEAPEST I
NONE OF THAT EVER CAME TO
FRUITION AT THIS POINT AND NOW
THE CITY'S LOOKING AT RE POWER A
GAS POWER PLANT.
AND THAT DEMAND MANAGEMENT IS NO
WHERE IN THE EQUATION BECAUSE
THAT FUNCTIONALITY IS NOT ONLINE
EVEN THOUGH THE SMART METERS ARE
CAPABLE OF DOING IT ON THEIR
APPS TO DO IT.
NONE OF THAT'S REALLY BEEN PUT
TOGETHER YET AND CERTAINLY THE
PRICING HASN'T BEEN INSTITUTED.
SO THIS IS THE NEXT LOGICAL STEP
TO EMPOWER REPAIRS. TO SAVE
MONEY -- THE WITH THE
INVESTMENTS THAT THEY'VE MADE
THROUGH SMART METERS AND ALSO
THROUGH BUYING APPLIANCES THAT
ARE SMART METER READY SO I THINK
THIS BILL IS GOING TO GO A LONG
WAY IN HELPING PUT ALL OF THAT
TOGETHER.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR COMING
FORWARD WITH THE BILL AND I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT OF TODAY.
THANK YOU I DO WE HAVE A MOTION
SO MOVED.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WAIVER ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM FOR SB FORTY NINE BY
SENATOR SKINNER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFER TO UTILITIES AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING CHAU.
EGGMAN HI EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I LOW MOAN.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY THANK MCCARTY
AYE MELENDEZ.
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
STONE. FOUR ONE FOUR ONE WILL BE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
THANK YOU. FIVE ONE SORRY OUR
NEXT SENATOR IS -- SENATOR DODD.
WITH.
SB TWO FIFTY THREE WELCOME
SENATOR AND WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY YOU'RE WELCOME TO PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- SP TWO FIFTY THREE
WOULD REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD NATIVE
CULTURE. TO ESTABLISH THE
MINISTER IN INCENTIVE BASED
CONSERVATION PROGRAM.
SB TWO FIVE THREE WOULD REQUIRE
THE PROGRAM TO OPTIMIZE WILDLIFE
HABITAT WILL SUPPORTING THE
ECONOMIC VIABILITY OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE THROUGH INCENTIVES
IN TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. TO
FARMERS AND RANCHERS MOVED WELL.
THEIR CULTURE IS A MAJOR
INDUSTRY HOWEVER THE MANAGEMENT
DECISION THE CONSERVATION
PRACTICES OF FARMERS AND
RANCHERS CAN ALSO DRAMATICALLY
ENHANCE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
PROVIDE REQUISITE RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES.
IT OFFER -- SOCIAL BENEFITS THE
PURPOSE OF INCENTIVE BASED
CONSERVATION PROGRAM IS TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
AGRICULTURE PRODUCERS WHO WANT.
TO VOLUNTARILY MAKE WILDLIFE
FRIENDLY IMPROVEMENTS ON THEIR
LAND.
A PART OF FUTURE APPROPRIATION
THE PROGRAM WOULD PROVIDE
FINANCIAL AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO AGRICULTURE
PRODUCERS WHO CREATE THESE --
BENEFITS -- SB TWO FIFTY THREE
CLEARLY INSTRUCTS THE DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD NAY OF CULTURE IT SURE
THE INCENTIVE BASED PROGRAM.
COMPLIMENTS AND NOT SO PLANTS
ANY OTHER EXISTING PROGRAMS
CONTRARY TO WHAT IS SUGGESTED BY
CAL CANCER LATE OPPOSITION.
I ALSO WANT TO POINTOUT THE CAL
KIDS SUGGESTION THAT SB TWO FIVE
THREE WALL OFF ANY PARTICULAR
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM.
SIMPLY BECAUSE IT CREATES
COMPETITION FOR OTHER PROGRAMS
SUPPORTED BY A CAL KIA IS
FRANKLY NONSENSE.
DETERMINING WHO GETS WHAT
FUNDING IS THE LEGISLATURE'S JOB
BASED ON OUR PRIORITIES EACH
YEAR IN THE BUDGET PROCESS IN
CONCLUSION I COMMITTEE YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
IN THE COMMITTEE THAT I WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE TO
ADDRESS HOW WE ESTABLISH.
PRIORITIZATION OF THE GRANT
PROGRAM SB TWO FIVE THREE IS
SUPPORTED BY THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WHICH IS HERE WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU WITNESSES PLEASE STAND
UP.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE WITH YOU TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL TWO
FIFTY THREE MY NAME IS JAY
ZIEGLER AND I'M THAT DIRECTOR
POLICY FOR THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY.
OF CALIFORNIA'S PRACTICALLY ONE
HUNDRED MILLION ACRES MORE THAN
40% OF THAT LANDSCAPE IS
DEDICATED TO WORKING FARMS AND
RANCHES.
ACROSS THE STATE THESE WORKING
LANDS PROVIDE CRITICALLY NEEDED
OPEN SPACE AND HABITAT -- THOSE
HABITAT NEEDS ARE ACTUALLY
GROWING -- MORE SEVERE AS
CLIMATE CHANGE -- CHANGES --
HABITAT PATTERNS -- AROUND US
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA -- IT IS
SENATOR DODD NOTES -- HIS
LEGISLATION WOULD ESTABLISH A
SPECIFIC PROGRAM TO ALLOW
AGRICULTURE PRODUCERS WHO WANT
TO VOLUNTARILY MAKE CONSERVATION
IMPROVEMENTS THEIR LANDS -- IN
KERRY COSTS -- FOR WATER AND
ENERGY -- WHICH ADD TO THE
WORKING LANDSCAPE COSTS OF
AGRICULTURE -- INTO THEIR LARGER
EQUATION -- SO -- THE
ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING INCENTIVE
PROGRAM AND THAT WOULD BE
CREATED AND SENATE BILL TWO
FIFTY THREE WOULD PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR WILDLIFE FRIENDLY
FENCING. TO ALLOW FOR WILDLIFE
MOVEMENT FLOODING OF RICE FIELDS
FOR MIGRATORY BIRD HABITAT --
AND SUCH PRACTICES IS GROWING
HEAD ROSE -- TO BENEFIT
POLLINATORS.
IN RECENT YEARS AND ESPECIALLY
DURING THE DROUGHT WE SOUGHT TO
BUILD DELIVERY OF ON FARM
CONSERVATION PRACTICES DECLINE
AT A PRECIPITOUS LEVEL.
IN FACT -- IN THE HEART OF THE
DROUGHT I ON PRIVATE LANDS THE
ONLY HABITAT THAT WAS PROVIDED
CAME FROM -- PROGRAM FUNDING FOR
THE NATURAL RESOURCE
CONSERVATION SERVICE OR PROGRAMS
OPERATED BY NON PROFITS -- IN
CALIFORNIA TO THE EVENT THAT
CRITICAL NEED -- FOR HABITAT
DIRECTED ACTIONS ON PRIVATE
LANDS IS GROWING MORE SEVERE --
AS AS SAID AS THE MONTHS AND
YEARS ARE PASSING.
MORE RESOURCES AND TOOLS -- ARE
NEEDED -- FOR CALIFORNIA'S
FARMERS AND RANCHERS TO DO S.
CLIMATE CHANGE -- AND ON FARM
PRACTICES ARE REALLY GOING TO BE
ESSENTIAL AND PROTECTING -- THE
QUALITY OF HABITAT FOR FISH --
WILDLIFE MIGRATORY BIRDS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE THANK AS
SENATOR DODD FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
IN THE US AND ASPER AYE VOTE ON
SENATE BILL TWO FIFTY THREE
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITH THE TEAR.
HI MY NAME IS KAREN BERMAN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS --
THE NINETY SIX OUR CITIES -- IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON CONSERVATION
ISSUES ON FARMLAND SINCE THE
DUST BOWL SO FOR OVER SEVENTY
FIVE YEARS WE'VE BEEN ALL
PARTNERING WITH LANDOWNERS TO
AND DO BETTER IS AS WELL AS
COMMUNITIES -- THE BIGGEST TOOL
THAT WE'VE HAD AS BEEN THE
NATURAL RESOURCE CONSERVATION
SERVICE BOTH OUR PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE AND THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THEY PROVIDE.
AND ESPECIALLY THE FUNDING THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE THROUGH
PROGRAMS LIKE THE EQUIPPED FOR
GRAHAM -- THAT IS IT'S IT
GREATLY -- ASSISTED US IN BEING
ABLE TO REDUCE NON POINT SOURCE
POLLUTION I'M SOIL EROSION
SEDIMENTATION CONSERVATION OF
AND PROMOTING CONSERVATION OF
GROUND AND SURFACE WATERS ENERGY
AND I HAVE BENEFITING OUT AT
RISK SPECIES -- OF WILD WILD
LIFE AND AND CREATING THEIR
HABITAT -- WE REALLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND BECAUSE HAVING THE
ANALOG TO THE NRCS WOULD GIVE US
A WHOLE NOTHER SET OF TOOLS TO
BE ABLE TO AND DO BETTER ON
FARMLAND AS WE KNOW WE HAVE A
LARGE NUMBER OF ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSERVATION ISSUES THAT ARE
FACING US.
WE NEED ALL THE TOOLS THAT WE
CAN GET -- AND DAD.
HAVING A AN ANALOG TO THE ENTER
CS WOULD PROVIDE A WHOLE
ADDITIONAL SET OF TOOLS THAT CAN
CAN HELP US GET TO THESE GOALS --
WE DO APPRECIATE THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE ALREADY OUT CDFA AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THOSE WE'VE
BEEN IMPLEMENTING THOSE WITH OUR
CITIES ALL OVER THE STATE -- BUT
WE THERE'S REALLY A LOT MORE
THAT WE NEED TO DO IN THERE'S A
LOT MORE INPUT NOT MORE
PRACTICES THAT WE NEED TO
IMPLEMENT -- SO WE REALLY SEE
TWO FIFTY THREE AS A WAY FOR
FARMERS SAID IMPLEMENT
COMPLEMENTARY PRACTICES AT THE
EXISTING CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE PROGRAM.
AND WE REALLY WANT TO SUPPORT
OUR FARMERS AND RANCHERS AND
BEING ABLE TO ACHIEVE ALL THE
GOALS THAT THEY HAVE FOR THEIR
OWN FARMLAND.
AND THANK YOU SENATOR DODD FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS -- THIS
EFFORT.
HE WAS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
WISHING TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MARK
FRANCE MAKER FOR THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY OPEN SPACE THIRTY
INSTRUCTS PORT.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE.
OKAY SO YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE WHAT
THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
HELLO JIMMY MERYL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK A MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- WE ARE A
COALITION OF SUSTAINABLE IN
ORGANIC AGRICULTURE
ORGANIZATIONS AND FORMER LEADERS.
AND WE ARE REGULARLY SEEKING
RESOURCES FOR FARMERS TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE -- SO
IT'S NOT.
WE DON'T LOOK FORWARD TO BEING
IN THIS PARTICULAR POSITION WITH
THE BILL -- BUT WE'VE BEEN
SEEKING WHAT WE THINK ARE SOME
PRETTY COMMONSENSE AMENDMENTS
BUT JUST HAVEN'T MADE THE
PROGRESS THAT WE HAD HOPED BY
NOW.
AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED SB TWO FIVE
THREE DOES NOT MAKE CLEAR HOW
THE NEWLY PROPOSED ENVIRONMENTAL
FARMING INCENTIVE PROGRAM IS
COMPLIMENTARY NOT DUPLICATIVE.
OF EXISTING CLAIMANTS MIGHT
AGRICULTURE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
WE HAD PROPOSED LANGUAGE THAT
THE ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING
SCIENCE ADVISORY PANEL THAT
OVERSEES -- CITY AFFAIRS
PROGRAMS.
SUGGEST HOW TO PURSUE THE
PRESENT STREAMLINING COORDINATED
APPLICATION PROCESSES FOR
FARMERS.
SO WE DON'T PRESENT THEM WITH
OVERLY COMPLEX IN BURDENS AND
APPLICATION SYSTEMS -- AND THAT
AMENDMENT WAS NOT A TAKEN
FORWARD WE ALSO SUGGESTED
CLARIFYING THAT THE INFORMAL
FARMING INCENTIVE PROGRAM IS
FOCUSED ON WILDLIFE HABITAT AND
NOT TO PLAY COULD HAVE OF SOME
OF THE PRACTICES ARE ELIGIBLE
UNDER THE CLAIM IT'S MINOR
CULTURE PROGRAMS.
AND WE WANTED TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
THE NEWLY PROPOSED PROGRAM IS
NOT INTENDED AS AN UMBRELLA AND
IT AND LENDS BY WHICH ALL
PRACTICES MUST MEET.
WE ALSO SUGGESTED THAT CURRENT
PRACTICES MADE ELIGIBLE BY THE
INFORMAL FARMING CENTER
PROGRAMMER NOT DUPLICATIVE OF
THOSE PRACTICES.
ALREADY ELIGIBLE UNDER THE CLAIM
IT'S MINOR CULTURE PROGRAM.
WE SUPPORT ADICIONAL RESOURCES
FOR FARMERS -- THE CURRENT
CLAIMS FOR AGRICULTURE PROGRAMS
AREN'T BIG ENOUGH WE HAVE WE CAN
APPRECIATE THAT -- BUT WE THINK
WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS NOT ENOUGH
OF A COORDINATED EFFORT -- BUT
REALLY GET SACKED ENHANCED
RESOURCES -- WE LIKE TO AVOID
CREATING CONFUSION ON THE GROUND
WITH FARMERS AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE.
A COMPLIMENTARY SET OF TECHNICAL
FINANCIAL AND RESEARCH RESOURCES
FOR FARMERS WERE INTERESTED IN
CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH THESE
ISSUES WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYBODY ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY SEEING NONE WILL MOVE BACK
TO THE DíAS TO SEE IF ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS.
SOME OF THE REAL AMOUNT IS HAVE
DINNER QUESTION I DON'T KNOW IF
THE AUTHOR WANTED TO RESPOND TO
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION CONCERNS
ARE -- YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE
MON -- WE HAVE.
HAD SEVERAL CONSULTATIONS --
WITH CAL CAN IN THE PROCESS --
WE THINK THAT -- THE ONE OF
THEIR SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS IS --
IT WOULD PROVIDE SORT OF DETAIL
DIRECTION -- NOT COMMONLY FOUND
IN LEGISLATION BUT WE THINK WE
CAN RESOLVE -- HOW TO ENSURE --
THAT THE APPLICATION PROCESS IS
STREAMLINED AND NOT DUPLICATE I
MEAN THAT'S REALLY THE INTENT OF
THIS LEGISLATION IS TO CREATE.
A CALIFORNIA ANALOG -- TO THE
INNER CS PROGRAMS AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AND CANDIDLY PROGRAMS THAT
WORK BETTER FOR SMALLER FARMERS
AND FOR SPECIALTY CROP FARMERS
IN CALIFORNIA -- THAT ARE NOT
WELL TAILORED IN A FEDERAL
PROGRAM TO THE STATES NEEDS FOR
PROVIDING HABITAT ON
AGRICULTURAL LAND SO I THINK
THAT -- WE HAVE A DIALOGUE GOING
I THINK THAT WE CAN ADDRESS --
MOST OF THESE CONCERNS -- AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT CONTINUE
DIALOGUE.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE.
OKAY -- THANK YOU BRING THE BILL
FOR IT I KNOW YOU'RE MOVING ON
TO AGRICULTURE NEXT AND I THINK
A LOT OF THESE ISSUES WILL BE
HASHED OUT -- IN THAT COMMITTEE
SO I'LL BE ABLE -- TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY AND HOPE TO SEE
IT BEFORE THANK YOU AND WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU.
WITH THE MOTION WE DO.
OKAY THAT'S FOR ROLL CALL PLEASE.
I TO MATE SB TWO FIFTY THREE BY
SENATOR DODD THE MOTION IS TO
PASS A REFER TO THE AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA FLOOR I'D CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
ALONE.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ WHERE.
THIRTY STONE. SIX ZERO SIX WAS
THE ROLE OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT UP WE HAVE SENATOR STERN
WITH SB.
SIX THIRTEEN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY CENTER THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
FIRST I JUST WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS APPRECIATE THE HARD
WORK DONE BY YOU AND YOUR STAFF
ON THIS.
WE TALK A LOT ABOUT GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSION REDUCTION
STRATEGIES AND OPPORTUNITIES OUT
THERE BUT VERY RARELY DO WE
FOCUS ON THE TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITIES -- IN THE FOOD
SECTOR -- WHEN IT COMES TO THE
AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY I THINK
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WERE
DOING SOME OF THE MOST ADVANCED
WORK IN THE WORLD -- WHEN IT
COMES TO GROWING OUR FOOD
SUSTAINABLY IN MANNERS THAT
REDUCE CARBON OR EVEN SEQUESTER
THAT CARBON?
AND I THINK IT'S TIME THE STATE
ACTUALLY DID THE MATH AND LOOKED
AT THE GREENHOUSE GAS IMPACT OF
THE FOOD WE BUY FOR OURSELVES
AND I THINK ONCE WE GET TO SOME
OF THE TRUTH OF THAT MATH --
WILL REALIZE THAT THERE ARE
pTO FEED OURSELVES BUT ALSO --
AND LOWER THE STATE'S CARBON
FOOTPRINT AT THE SAME TIME AND
HOPEFULLY IN A MANNER THAT --
INCENTIVIZE IS OUR OUR GROWERS
IN OUR FARMERS TO KEEP DOING THE
GOOD WORK THEY'RE DOING -- SO
THAT'S THE SIMPLE THRUST THE
BILL BUT I'M HAPPY TO DIG INTO
ANY QUESTIONS -- DETAILS AND
I'VE GOT SOMEONE MUCH SHARPER
THAN I I NICK FASCIOLA WITH THE
DIRECTOR WHO IS THE DIRECTOR
CARBON PROJECTS AT THREE DEGREES
TO TALK ABOUT.
SOME OF THE NUANCES TO CARBON
INVENTORYING OR WHAT REALLY GOES
INTO A REPORT CARD FOR THE STATE
BUT I'LL LEAVE IT THERE FOR NOW
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SO DID YOU WANT ME
WITNESSES WITNESS TO BE
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS. TO
SPEAK DURING IT MIGHT WANT TO
MAKE A COMMENT YOU CAME ALL THIS
WAY IS THAT RIGHT.
OKAY THANK YOU VENTURE.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS -- AND EXPRESS YOUR
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEER AND THE
DIRECTOR OF CORPORATE PROJECTS
AT THREE DEGREES SAN FRANCISCO
BASED BE CORPORATION THAT HELPS
CORPORATE UTILITIES INC AND THE
CUSTOMERS. TO TAKE URGENT ACTION
ON CLIMATE CHANGE THROUGH CARBON
MARKETS -- WE'VE ALSO BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF GREENHOUSE GAS INVENTORIES
FOR RESTAURANTS -- THAT INCLUDE
THE SCOPE THREE LIFECYCLE
EMISSIONS FROM THE PRODUCTION
AND ACQUISITION.
OF INGREDIENTS SERVED AT THE
RESTAURANT.
I'M HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL SIX
THIRTEEN TO REQUIRED THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO CREATE AND
PUBLISH.
ON ITS INTERNET WEBSITE A
METHODOLOGY FOR STATE AGENCY
DECIMATED FOOD RELATED
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AS
PROVIDED.
AND WOULD REQUIRE STATE AGENCY
TO USE THIS METHODOLOGY TO
PREPARE ITS ESTIMATE IS ESTIMATE
OF THOSE EMISSIONS.
BY TESTING A OR B. WITH
DEVELOPMENT OF METHODOLOGY WHICH
CAN RELY ON AN ABUNDANCE OF
EXISTING RESEARCH AND LIFE CYCLE
ANALYSIS OF FOOD.
SO THAT STATE AGENCIES CAN
INCLUDE FOOD EMISSIONS WITHIN
THE STATE AGENCY GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION REPORT CARD.
SB SIX THIRTEEN COULD LEAD TO
SIGNIFICANT OPPORTUNITIES TO
MAKE THIS TO MEET THE STATE'S
CLIMATE OBJECTIVES. FOR ANY GAPS
IN THE SCIENCE BETWEEN
CONVENTIONAL AND MORE
PROGRESSIVE CLIMATE BENEFICIAL
FOOD SYSTEMS THIS BILL COULD
SERVE TO PROMOTE AND ENCOURAGE
FURTHER LIFE CYCLE ASSESSMENT
STUDIES ON THESE RESPECTIVE
SYSTEMS.
THE NEW SCIENCE IN TURN CAN BE
FOLDED INTO METHODOLOGY
REVISIONS THAT WOULD FURTHER
SPUR THE STATE'S VENDORS TO
UTILIZE FOOD PRODUCTION SYSTEMS
THAT HARNESS THESE PROGRESSIVE
PRACTICES.
OF THE FORTY SOMETHING
RESTAURANTS THAT HAVE RECEIVED A
GREENHOUSE GAS ASSESSMENT FROM
THREE DEGREES WE'VE OBSERVED A
FAIR AMOUNT OF ENGAGEMENT BY THE
RESTAURANT OWNERS TO IDENTIFY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR REDUCTIONS.
WE OFTEN RECEIVE SUCH QUESTIONS
AS IS GRASS FED BEEF LESS
GREENHOUSE GAS INTENSIVE THAN
FEEDLOT BEEF.
OR DID YOU ACCOUNT FOR THE LOCAL
OYSTERS WE PURCHASE FROM TAMALES
BAY THAT ARE SUSTAINABLY
HARVESTED.
WHILE WE DON'T ALWAYS HAVE A
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING ON THE
ACTUAL GREENHOUSE GAS SAVINGS
FROM ONE SYSTEM OVER ANOTHER.
I BRING THIS UP TO ILLUSTRATE
THE TYPE OF THINKING THAT HAS
SPURRED BY ASSESSING THE
LIFECYCLE EMISSIONS.
FROM FOOD PRODUCTION.
WHEN THE STATE'S VENDORS ARE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO THIS LEVEL
TRANSPARENCY IT IS LIKELY TO
ENGAGE MANY THOUGHTFUL
DISCUSSIONS AROUND ALTERNATIVE
FOODS PROCUREMENT WITH LOWER
GREENHOUSE GAS INTENSITIES?
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON SIX THIRTEEN
AND THANK SENATOR STERN FOR ALL
DURING THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THANK YOU FOR ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL.
RATED ALSO AS THE ACT OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE ANYBODY HERE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
OKAY SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SOME
NUMBER EGGMAN.
THANK YOU -- SINCE IT.
SO ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT FOOD
AND IT'S CONCEPTION.
THE FULL LIFECYCLE THE FULL LIFE
CYCLE FROM GROWING ALL THE WAY
TO OUR PLACE IN THE STATE
CAPITAL.
WITH THE READ WITH THE WITH THE
GOAL OF UNDERSTANDING A BETTER
OR REDUCING IT OR THERE'S NO
MANDATE FOR REDUCTION IN HERE
BUT WE WE FEEL LIKE IF WE HAVE A
MORE ACCURATE INVENTORY WE'RE
GONNA HAVE OPPORTUNITIES TO SAY.
FRIENDS IT'S A D. G. S. OKAY
YOU'RE GOING TO BUY.
FOOD.
FOR THIS THAT THE STATE
LEGISLATURE FRIENDS AND AND YOU
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE BY
LOWER CARBON FOODS A PRODUCE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA OR
SOMETHING ELSE WHERE -- YOU KNOW
GIVING THEM THAT INFORMATION WE
FEEL LIKE THEY'RE GONNA MAKE
SMARTER CHOICES BECAUSE THE
OVERALL MANDATE IS.
TO REDUCE CARBON SO. TO TRY TO
BE AS THOROUGH AS WE CAN ALL THE
WAY UPSTREAM WELL HELLO.
BUT HOW WILL WE KNOW OUT OF
COSTS.
FOR OKAY SO I MEAN THE THE MOST
ACCURATE DATA WE CAN POSSIBLY
GET OBVIOUSLY IS IN STATE WHERE
WE HAVE CONTROL ALL THE WAY OVER
THE SOURCE AND YOU CAN GO TO A
FARM IN OR STAND THEIR PRACTICES --
BUT THE ESTIMATES AND OUR OUR
OUR FRIEND HERE FROM THREE
DEGREES IN PROBABLY WAY IN
BETTER BUT THEIR THEIR ESTIMATES
DID LOOK AT SAY INDIRECT LAND
USE CHANGE IMPACTS FROM HOW THEY
DO -- DAIRY PRODUCTION SAY IN
NEW ZEALAND OR BRAZIL VERSES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT -- THEY CAN AT
LEAST GET SOMETHING THAT'S
QUANTIFIABLE AND TRANSPARENT
EVEN IF IT'S NOT PERFECT IT'S
SOMETHING DIRECTIONAL SO I DON'T.
I I DON'T OVER PROMISE WITH THIS
IT IS GOING TO BE COMPLETELY
PERFECT MATH BUT LIKE OUR LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD IN SOME OF
THESE OTHER -- TOOLS WE'VE GOT
THE MATH ISN'T YOU KNOW -- WHEN
WHEN YOU GET IN INTERNATIONAL
MARKETS IT IT REALLY IS
DEPENDENT ON GETTING THEM TO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR SYSTEM SO IN
THEORY?
THEY WOULD PROVIDE BETTER DATA
ADDED SOME OF THESE FOREIGN
JURISDICTIONS TO IF THEY THEY
WANT TO COMPETE IN CALIFORNIA.
HI I MEAN JUST BECAUSE LIKE WHAT
HAPPENS WITH SOME OF OUR OTHER
THINGS WITH WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO
CONTROL MORE IS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH WE ALREADY HAVE
THE MOST.
CONTROLLED FOOD SUPPLY IN THE
WORLD I DON'T THINK MANY WOULD
ARGUE AND SO.
IF WE'RE LOOKING AT REDUCING
CARBON THROUGH THAT VERSES
GLOBALLY I GUESS I JUST THEM I
AM VERY CONFUSED ABOUT HOW THIS
WOULD WORK I MEAN.
MY THESIS IN THIS IS HOPEFULLY
JUST A STEP TO GET SOME
TRANSPARENCY IN DATA INTO THE
SYSTEM BUT I THINK I AGREE WITH
YOU I THINK CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE IS THE LEADER IN THE
WORLD AND I DON'T THINK THEY'RE
GETTING ENOUGH CREDIT FRANKLY
FOR THE WORK THEY'RE DOING AND
SO.
HOPEFULLY BY DOING SOME OF THE
SOME OF THIS CARBON INVENTORY
WORK WILL BE ABLE TO BRING THAT%
TO LIGHT SAY IN OUR DAIRY
INDUSTRY OR IN OUR BEEF INDUSTRY
OR IN.
IN A SPECIALTY CROPS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT SO THAT THAT'S THE
HOPING JUST STARTING WITH
SOMETHING WE DO HAVE CONTROL
OVER WHICH IS THE STATE'S FOOD
BUDGET THIS DOESN'T GET INTO.
WHAT WE NEEDED PRIVATE
RESTAURANTS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
BUT HOPEFULLY THE MARKET STARTS
TO GO THAT WAY I THINK IT COULD
BE A BIG LIFT [inaudible]
FOR CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
ANYBODY ELSE [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MELENDEZ
[inaudible]
WHY HAD?
SOME OF THE SAME QUESTIONS AT MY
COLLEAGUE DID -- WHO IS EXCLUDED
FROM HAVING TO TURN IN THIS
REPORT?
WHO IS EXCLUDED IS THERE ANY
STATE IT OKAY BECAUSE WHAT I
HAVE IS A DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
IS EXCLUDED?
THE DEPARTMENT OF BUYS A LOT OF
FOOD.
RIGHT.
THIS IS JUST FOR THE STATE
AGENCY GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
REPORT CARD MIGHT BE CDC ARE IS
A STATE AGENCY.
SURE -- SO YOU'RE GETTING IT I'M
SORRY SO YOU'RE SAYING THE
PROJECT THEY SHOULDN'T YOU.
SHOULDN'T BE EXEMPTED -- OR YOU
KNOW I'M SAYING THEY ARE
EXEMPTED AND I'M WONDERING --
WHY THAT IS?
WELL I THINK THEY'RE ALREADY
GOING THROUGH -- THE PURCHASING
SYSTEM THROUGH TGS RIGHT NOW IS
MY UNDERSTANDING I DON'T KNOW IF
ANYONE IS HERE FROM ANY OF THE
AGENCIES BUT I DIDN'T KNOW THAT
WE HAD EXEMPTED -- THAT SECTOR.
SO I MISSED THAT.
PARDON ME IF YOU CAN GET SOME
CLARITY HERE.
I I DID NOT KNOW THAT WE HAD YET
THE AYE MEANS ANY STATE AGENCY
SO -- KATIE DO YOU WANT.
TO PULL UP THE SECTION PLEASE.
IF I MIGHT PERHAPS IT'S BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE TO DO THE REPORT
CARD.
SO.
UNTIL THE EXPLICITLY EXEMPT THEM
BUT NOT THEY'RE NOT SUBJECT TO
THE REPORT CARD THAT'S A MINIMAL
INTO.
ABSOLUTELY I DID THAT MIGHT THAT
MIGHT MAKE A LOT OF SENSE -- I
YEAH I I I DIDN'T EVEN TEND TO
EXPECT EXPRESSLY AS M. THEM IN
THE LANGUAGE OF THAT THIS
MEASURE BUT I THINK THE CHAIR
JUST HELP ME OUT THERE -- IF
THEY'RE NOT CURRENTLY SUBJECT TO
THAT REPORTING PROTOCOL WITHIN
THE STATE OKAY I'M SO I'M VERY
OPEN TO THAT THAT THAT'S NOT A
BAD IDEA AT ALL [inaudible]
WELL -- OKAY [inaudible]
I AM.
I WAS LISTENING TO YOUR TO YOUR
RESPONSE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN ABOUT -- YOU KNOW HOW DO
YOU.
HOW DO YOU GAUGE THE SERVICE
FOOD COMING FROM OUTSIDE THE
STATE OR EVEN OUTSIDE OF THE
COUNTRY WHICH IS?
DIFFICULT YOU KNOW SOME
COUNTRIES MIGHT HAVE THAT DATA
SOME MAY NOT WE CERTAINLY KNOW
THAT THERE A LOT OF COUNTRIES
WHO ARE AS EAGER. TO ADDRESS
ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGES AS
CALIFORNIA IS BUT NOT
NECESSARILY THAT THEY'RE
COLLECTING THE DATA SO
[inaudible]
I GUESS.
HOW IS IT THAT WE WOULD STOP --
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
BUSINESSES FROM -- BEING EDGED
OUT BY WRITER DUAL STANDARD RATE
SOLVE ANY INFORMATION YEAH DO
YOU WANNA COME I JUST HOW YOU
DEAL WITH IT RIGHT NOW IN THE
RESTAURANT SECTOR FOR THOSE
ORGANIC I THINK I WOULD ACTUALLY
HELP CLEAR SOME HEARINGS OUTSIDE
AND THIS WILL HELP CLEAR THINGS.
I THINK IT'S HELP CLEARED UP --
REALLY THE BEST WAY TO TO
MEASURE THE LIFE CYCLE
ASSESSMENT OF FOODS IS THROUGH --
LOOK.
FRIENDS OF STUDIES OF THE
SYSTEMS THEMSELVES RATHER THAN
THE FOLLOWING THE ACTUAL CHAIN
OF EVENTS THAT BROUGHT THE FOOD
TO THE PLATE HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
EXACT ACCOUNTING -- OF EACH AND
EVERY FOOD SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW REPEATEDLY THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR BUT MORE OF A YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT DOES IT TAKE TO
PRODUCE.
A POTATO WHAT IS A PRETTY TAKE
TO PRODUCE -- YOU KNOW --
WATERMELON OR CHICKEN -- AND
FROM THAT YOU HAVE SORT OF A YOU
CAN YOU CAN MAKE A NUMBER AND
PUT IN A DATABASE.
AND THAT NUMBER COULD BE USED
WITHOUT REALLY -- HOLDING ANY
PARTICULAR -- YOU KNOW.
IT'S IT'S NOT LIKE YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE EMISSIONS ACROSS
THE DIFFERENT COUNTRIES THAT MAY
HAVE BROUGHT THAT WATER DOWN
HERE BUT THE OVERALL.
IMPACT OF THAT WATERMELON.
HERE ON THE PLATE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND SO OVER TIME WE MIGHT FIND
THAT THERE IS -- WATERMELONS
PRODUCED -- SOMEONE THE WAITER
AND ALSO WATERMELONS.
A LITTLE BIT CLOSER TO
CALIFORNIA -- THERE MAY BE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THOSE.
TWO FROM A SYSTEMATIC VIEW
POINTS AND THEN THAT CAN LEAD TO
DECISION MAKING AROUND THE MORE
LOCAL PRODUCTS.
AND IF I COULD JUST ADD I THINK.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN AT LEAST THE
AIRPORT YOU IN THE PAST AND
THEY'VE DONE THESE INVENTORIES
WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE THE DATA?
THEY PICK A HIGH BASELINE FOR
YOU AND YOU'RE STUCK WITH THE
DEFAULT IF YOU CAN PROVIDE THE
DATA THEN YOU CAN PROVE THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO BE LOWER THAN
THAT RIGHT.
BUT I THINK.
I I I HAVE QUITE THE OPPOSITE
INTENT TO DO ANYTHING TO BUY
SINCE STATE FARMERS AYE I
ACTUALLY THINK IS GOING TO BE A
BOOST FOR THEM STATION THAT.
PUSHES BACK AGAINST OUT OF STATE
COMMERCE -- BUT LOOKING AT
CARBON I THINK IS ACTUALLY A
REALLY USEFUL TOOL THAT GIVE US
CREDIT FOR ALL THE WORK THEY'RE
DOING IN STATE AND THEN THOSE
WHO AT A STATE THEY DON'T WANT.
TO GIVE US THAT INFORMATION WELL
I MEAN IT'S UP TO THE AGENCY
REPORT CARD PROCESS BUT IN
THEORY YOU KNOW YOU GET HIT WITH
A HIGH SCORE AND THAT'S A STACK
UP.
I MEAN THAT THAT'S THE THAT'S
THE INTENT OF THE BILL AND I'M
OPEN TO TRYING TO REFINE THAT TO
REALLY MAKE CLEAR THAT.
WE DON'T WANT TO BE AN
ADDITIONAL REGULATORY BURDEN ON
OUR END STATE FOLKS -- BUT I
THINK THE MATH WILL HELP US.
OKAY AND JUST A FINAL THOUGHT WE
DON'T -- I I SINCE YOU DON'T
SHARE MY CONCERN THAT THIS MIGHT
BE A WAY -- TO MANIPULATE THIS
PARTICULAR MARKET [inaudible]
FINANCIALLY.
BY BY HAVING THESE REQUIREMENTS
IN BY DECIDING WHO.
GETS IN AND WHO DOES IN AND WHO
YOU KNOW IF YOU CAN'T AFFORD TO
MEET THE MARK CAN AFFORD TO
PRODUCE THE DATA OR THEIR YOU
KNOW WHATEVER IT IS WE NEED --
HI.
HAS A CRUSH YOUR MIND.
YES SO FROM ONE FOR MINOR SAY
THE CURRENT REPORTING A REPORT
CARD SYSTEM.
THERE'S WE'RE NOT IMPOSING ANY
NEW REGULATIONS ON INDUSTRIES TO
PROVIDE DATA THE STATE WOULD BE
THE ONE OBLIGATED TO GO TO THAT
WORK.
SO I'M NOT AS WORRIED ABOUT THIS
SORT OF BACK DURING A MANDATE OR
ADDING SAY IN NEW EXPENSIVE
REPORTING PROTOCOL ON A
WATERMELON GROWER OR BEEF PRETTY
SURE ANYBODY -- MY THINKING IS
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF REALLY
GOOD METHODOLOGIES OFF THE SHELF
SITTING THERE RIGHT NOW STATES
JUST NOT USING HIM RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY IS ONE I TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT [inaudible]
AS THE BUT I APPRECIATE THE
APPRECIATE THE CONCERN YOU'RE
YOU'RE NOT OFF BASE IN.
I I DO SHARE THAT CONCERN.
YEAH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
OKAY DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
ROLL TOP ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM ELEVEN SB SIX THIRTEEN BY
SENATOR STERN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO CHILD [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
GARCIA.
THE EYES Là MON.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ THE LENDERS KNOW
MURATSUCHI STONE. THREE THREE
WILL HOLD THE RULER CRAFTED
MEMBERS THING TO KEEP WORKING ON
THIS.
SENATOR NIELSEN HAS BEEN VERY
PATIENT.
SENATOR MUCH WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND.
BUT THE FLOOR IS YOURS WELL I
THANK YOU FOR THAT THE
AUSPICIOUS BEGINNING.
LET ME JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THIS IS PART OF THE SOLUTION TO
THE FUTURE FOR THESE WILDFIRES
THAT HAVE BEEN SO RAVISHING THIS
DEALS WITH ONLY TWO COUNTIES --
EXPECTED CAN BE KIND OF A PILOT
OF HOW WE CAN ESTABLISH SUCH A
FUNDED WOULD BE AS APPROPRIATED
BY THE LEGISLATURE.
BUT THE REALITY OF IT IS ONE WE
DO HAVE THESE FIRES.
IF THEY'RE NOT TOO SEVERE THAT
LAND CAN [inaudible]
RECOVER.
BUT IN SOME CASES IT TAKES A LOT
OF HELP IN SOME CASES THE SOIL
ITSELF IS STERILIZED FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME.
AND THIS IS TRYING TO SET UP.
WITH APPROPRIATION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE OF THE GRANT PROGRAM
TO THOSE COUNTIES WHO HAVE BEEN
DESIGNATED WITH THESE DISASTERS.
AND DECLARED BY THE GOVERNOR AND
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THEN
WE COULD.
GIVE THEM A LITTLE BIT OF HELP.
TO RESTORE -- THE MOST ASSUREDLY
THAT'S GOING TO BE VERY
NECESSARY IN THE FUTURE BUT
WE'RE A LONG WAYS FROM BEING OUT
OF THE SHALL I SAY WOODS FOR
THESE FIRES.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND CAN I JUST
CLARIFY WHETHER YOU'LL BE TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS THE COMMITTEE
WHEN I WOULD HAPPILY ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AND THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH US ON YOUR
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED IN THIS
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS THANK YOU AND
YOU HAVE A WITNESS HERE TO
TESTIFY.
YOUR SINGLE PICKY WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THE WILDFIRES THAT WE'VE HAD
THAT WE'VE SEEN LATELY HAVE HAD
A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON OUR
pTHERE WAS A STUDY DONE IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BY THE U. S.
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY WHICH STATED
THAT WILD FIRES COULD DOUBLE THE
AMOUNT OF SETTLEMENT IN A THIRD
OF THE LARGEST WESTERN
WATERSHEDS BY.
TWENTY FIFTY AND IN SOME AREAS
SETTLEMENT COULD INCREASE BY
1000% POTENTIALLY CARRYING
PARASITES AND HARMFUL METALS AND
CHEMICALS WITH IT.
SB TWO TWENTY SIX WOULD GREATLY
ASSIST COUNTIES AFFECTED BY THE
MOST RECENT WILD FIRES TO
PROVIDE RESTORATION TORE STATES
CRITICAL WATERSHEDS.
AS FOR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
JOHN KENNEDY WITH RC RC THE
RURAL COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR CHRISTOPHER KAYLEE --
IF ON BEHALF OF HUMBLE MENDOCINO
REDWOOD COMPANIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
JOHNSON CLAIMED AFTER THE COUNTY
SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
JULIE HALL WITH ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES HERE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU WITHOUT I'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
BOB IS THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT I AM VERY HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL. TO A WE
HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE MULTIPLE
SECOND SO I CAN WE HAVE ROLL
CALL PLEASE THANK YOU.
ITEM SEVEN SB TWO TWENTY SIX BY
CENTER NIELSEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA FLORA AYE CHAU
[inaudible]
EGGMAN.
GARCIA.
GARCIA ISLA MON.
Là MON I MATHIS MATHIS I
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE MURATSUCHI
STONE. SIX ZERO SIX ZERO BELIEVE
THE ROLE OF THE PROPS AND
MEMBERS THING THAT YOU'RE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE IN YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU AND IS SENATOR MORE
LOCK.
EN ROUTE OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH.
YES LET'S GO THROUGH IN -- GO
THROUGH THE BILLS FOR MEMBERS TO
ADD ON START.
WITH AN ITEM ONE AJ ARE AND WE
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND ROLL
CALL PLEASE.
I ONE AJ ARE TEN BY MEMBER
RADIUS LOTION IS BE ADOPTED
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING CHAU
[inaudible]
EGGMAN.
GARCIA GARCIA I'LL AMONG.
THE MON I MATHIS.
AT THIS NOT VOTING SORRY OKAY.
ITEM THREE SB FORTY THREE BY
MEMBER ALLEN TO PASS THE REFER
TO REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE CURRENT GOAL IS.
FIVE TWO TWO WITH THE CHORE
VOTING I AND THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO.
ABSENT MEMBERS LIMóN.
LIMON AYE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO
RIGHT TO CHEAT STONE
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
OKAY. SIX FOUR SEVEN NUMBERS.
WHAT WENT WITH HIM AND --
BECAUSE IT WILL HELP AT THE END
WE MAY HAVE MORE MEMBERS TO VOTE.
OKAY SENATOR MOORE Là.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IT'S GOOD
TO BE HERE.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
WILDFIRES ARE CERTAINLY THE
MAJOR SUBJECT OF THIS YEAR IT'S
CERTAINLY A FEMALE I DON'T WANT
TO BELABOR THAT SUBJECT BUT WHAT
IS IMPRESSED UPON ME AFTER THREE
YEARS OF PURSUING LEGISLATIVE
EFFORTSIN THE PREVENTION SPACE.
IS THE MASSIVE AMOUNT OF
GREENHOUSE GASES THAT ARE
CREATED BY WILDFIRES.
CONSEQUENTLY I WAS SURPRISED AT
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
DIDN'T INCLUDE THIS MAN MADE
SOURCE IN THEIR PIE CHARTS ON
THEIR WEBSITE OR ANYWHERE IN
THEIR CALCULATIONS SO I'VE BEEN
TRYING TO UNDERGROUND CERTAIN
POWER LINES AND WHILE.
ARE WILDFIRES OWNS.
SO WHY SHOULD INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES CARE ABOUT UPGRADING
THEIR GRADES AND TRANSMISSION
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IF CARB ISN'T EVEN DOCUMENTING
THE PARTICULAR MATTER AND
GREENHOUSE GASES THERE NEGLECT
HAS BEEN CREATING.
OR MAYBE IN THE FUTURE WE CAN
SHOW HOW THEIR IMPROVING.
ESTATE.
PARTNER ARE ELECTRICAL ASSETS SO
MADAM CHAIR I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO PROVIDING A COMPLETE.
DATA ON HOW THIS STATE IS
ADDRESSING THE REDUCTION OF
GREENHOUSE GASES IN A HOLISTIC
MANNER AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE AND I HAVE LEE IS
SILVERTHORNE.
AS MY PRIMARY WITNESS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LEASE OR THE ARM OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
CAL CHAMBER SUPPORTS SB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE BECAUSE IT WILL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DATA FROM
WHICH TO MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS
ON LONG TERM GREENHOUSE GAS
PROGRAMS.
EXISTING LAW PASSED LAST YEAR
REQUIRES THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AND DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY TO
COLLABORATE TO ESTABLISH A
HISTORIC BASELINE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FOR PRE FIRE
SUPPRESSION AGES.
THIS BILL CONTINUES THAT DATA
GATHERING ENDEAVOR PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL DATA ON A GOING
FORWARD BASIS BY CATEGORY
INCLUDING BOTH AND ANTHROPOGENIC
SOURCES AN INCREASE FIRED
RESULTING FROM THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
IN THIS MANNER THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD WILL HAVE SUFFICIENT DATA
TO MAKE SCIENCE BASE DECISIONS
ON GHG REDUCTION ACTIVITIES AND
TO MAKE COST EFFECTIVE USE OF
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDS.
HAVING SUFFICIENT DATA DOES MAKE
DECISION MAKING EASIER PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY AND
ALLOWS FUNDS TO BE USED.
AND PUT IN USE WHERE THEY WILL
HAVE THE MOST EMOTIONAL IMPACT
IN REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN ORDER TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA IS A VICIOUS GOALS.
FOR THESE REASONS AND OTHERS CAL
CHAMBER SPORTS SB.
FIVE THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU ANY
OTHER WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
YOUR SINGLE PICKY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THE BILL.
JOHN KENNEDY WITH RC RC THE
RURAL COUNTIES AGAIN IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR CHRIS MCKAY WE ONLY
HAVE A HUMBOLDT MENACING A
REDWOOD COMPANIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU IS FOR ANYBODY WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
THANK YOU WILL WHICH TURNED OUT
TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
WITH MANY MEMBERS.
OKAY -- YOU DO HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND AYE I WILL -- FOR MY
SELF JUST SAY I I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY I DO
HAVE A SLIGHT CONCERN.
THAT THIS INFORMATION IS ALREADY
AVAILABLE CAL FIRE DOES LOOK AT
AIR QUALITY ISSUES FROM A
WILDFIRE CERTAINLY AND THERE'S
CERTAINLY NO THOUGHT THAT WILD
FIRES ARE GOOD FOR AIR QUALITY.
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT THEY DO
CONTRIBUTE TO GREENHOUSE GASES
SO I DO WONDER HOW NECESSARY
THIS.
IS TO INCLUDE THIS -- YOU KNOW
I'M KIND OF A SMALL GOVERNMENT
KIND OF PERSON SO SOMETIMES I'M
WORRIED THAT WE WERE CREATING
YOU KNOW -- A LOT OF KIND OF
BUSY WORK FOR PEOPLE AND BUT I'M
I'M HAPPY I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS TODAY -- WITH THAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WITH THANK YOU
MA'AM SURE AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONCERNS.
MY CONCERNS HAVE BEEN THAT WE'VE
HAD A BIG BLIND SPOT WE'RE NOT
SEEING THE TOTAL IMPACT OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING TO OUR ENVIRONMENT
SO I I'D LIKE TO ENCOURAGE THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
TO PROVIDE MORE DATA.
SO THAT WE CAN AT LEAST
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING AND
THEN TRY TO REDUCE OUR WHILE
BUYERS -- AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
WE'RE PURSUING THIS ENDEAVOR I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WITH A MOTION A SECOND
WAVE ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM NINE SB FIVE THIRTY FIVE BY
SENATOR MORE LOCK THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
GARCIA.
GARCIA I LIMóN.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
AT THIS AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
AYE MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible] SEVEN ZERO THE
PROPS AND MEMBERS SPECIES THANK
YOU YOU SENATOR GALGIANI WELCOME.
IN YOUR HERE WITH.
SB.
ONE THIRTY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR
THOSE VERY GOOD SUGGESTIONS.
AS WILDFIRES HAVE BECOME LARGER
MORE FREQUENT THROUGHOUT HE
STATE EFFORTS TO NOTIFY AND
ALERT THE PUBLIC IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
HAVE BECOME INCREASINGLY
IMPORTANT SB ONE THIRTY
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
DIRECTING CAL FIRE TO CREATE A
PERMANENT GRANT PROGRAM TO
INSTALL AND IMPLEMENT AN
EMERGENCY FIRE SIREN WARNING
SYSTEM. FOR CITIES THAT ARE
DEEMED BY CAL FIRE TO BE IN A
VERY HIGH HAZARD SEVERITY SOUNDS.
SEVERAL COMPANIES IN AND AROUND
CALIFORNIA PROVIDE THIS
TECHNOLOGY AND WITH ME TODAY IS
A REPRESENTATIVE FROM JUST ONE
OF THESE COMPANIES DAVID SH NOW
FROM L. READ CORPORATION TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
REGARDING SPEAKERS AND SIREN
IMPLEMENTATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR RIVAL.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAKERS HE HERE FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
QUESTION ANSWERING.%
UP TO MY MANAGER MEMBERS -- I'M
DAVE SMELL -- VICE PRESIDENT OF
ALL RIGHT CORPORATION AND SAN
DIEGO.
WERE A PUBLICLY TRADED COMPANY
WE'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS SINCE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY AND WE MAKE
SPEAKERS -- THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY A
LOT MORE SOPHISTICATED THAN JUST
SPEAKERS.
OUR PRIMARY PRODUCT LINE IS
SOMETHING CALLED ACOUSTIC
HAILING DEVICES VERY LONG RANGE --
INCREDIBLY CLEAR SPEAKERS IF
YOU'VE EVER HEARD ONE THEY ARE
JUST COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THAN
ANYTHING ELSE ON THE MARKET WE
HAVE A SECONDARY PRODUCT LINE
THAT'S RELEVANT TO THIS
CONVERSATION AND THAT IS.
MASS NOTIFICATION SPEAKERS THE
PUT OUT THAT.
CLEAR LONG RANGE SOUND THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY DEGREES WERE IN
SEVENTY TWO COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD.
AND WE WE FEEL THAT -- YOU KNOW
THE THE IDEA OF MASS
NOTIFICATION FOR SPECIFIC THE
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE AN EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT IS IS -- SPOT ON AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT OUR
COMPANY AND A LOT OF OTHER
COMPANIES OUT THERE WOULD BE
VERY INTERESTED IN PURSUING.
THE WE'RE UNIQUE IN THAT WOULD
PROVIDE A MULTI LAYERED APPROACH
SPEAKERS AND SOFTWARE YOU'RE ALL
FAMILIAR WITH THIS MAYBE LIMIT
YOUR COMMENTS TO THE BILL ITSELF.
YEAH -- NO NOT AT ALL OKAY -- SO
WE THINK THAT IT'S VERY RELEVANT
TO THE COMPLEX ISSUE OF
PREPARING FOR A MITIGATING
RESPOND IN CALIFORNIA FOR ME
WILD FIRES A LOT OF CALIFORNIA.
COMMUNITIES HAVE MOVED FORWARD --
IN IMPLEMENTING THIS KIND OF
APPROACH MILL VALLEY CALIFORNIA
BEING THE MOST RECENT.
ONE LAGUNA BEACH PRIOR TO THAT
HOWEVER -- MOST COMMUNITIES DO
NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES THAT
COMMUNITIES LIKE LAGUNA BEACH
AND MILL VALLEY áP -- AND SO WE
FEEL THAT -- HEY GRANT PROGRAM
AS PROPOSED IN SB ONE THIRTY IS
VERY RELEVANT TO HELP A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES IT WILL MEET THE
SAME KIND OF SYSTEMS -- THAT
THEY MAY NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES
FOR SO WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT SB.
ONE THIRTY OKAY THANK YOU AS OR
ELSE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
NOT A MEMO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CHARLES WATSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY MELD IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND IS OR ANYBODY TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
OKAY SEEING NONE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ADULTS.
THANK YOU AND I I WILL JUST SAY
BEFORE WE CALL FOR A VOTE THAT
I'VE HAD A CONSTITUENTS -- CALL
AND WRITE AND SAY WE'VE GOT
THESE OLD SIREN SYSTEMS IN OUR
AREAS.
LEFT OVER FROM THE COLD WAR DAYS
AND CAN WE USE THEM FOR WILD
FIRE SO I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE LOOKING -- FOR THIS TOOL TO
BE ADDED TO NOTIFICATION SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
DECLARED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A ROLL CALL ME.
ITEM FIVE SB ONE THIRTY BY
SENATOR GALGIANI THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
GARCIA.
GARCIA I LIMóN.
LIMON AYE MATHIS MATHIS I
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
AYE MURATSUCHI STONE. SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN ZERO YOUR BILL ITSELF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY LET'S GO BACK NOW AND GO
THROUGH FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY ON ITEM ONE AJ ARE TEN BY
RADIUS MOTION IS BE ADOPTED
CURRENT VOTE IS.
THREE TO ONE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I AND THE VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING.
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHOW I EGGMAN [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY AYE.
RIGHT TO CHOOSE [inaudible]
STONE.
DIDN'T DISMISS MELENDEZ TO
REPORT ABOUT HER.
YES SO THAT'S FIVE TO ONE ITEM
THREE SB FORTY THREE BY ALAN.
DO PASS REFER TO REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE CURRENT BEAU
IS SIX TO THREE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I AM THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO.
ABSENT MEMBERS RIGHT TO CHI.
AND STONE. FIFTY FIVE RESURGENT
TONIGHT RIGHT.
HI. SEVEN THREE SEVEN THREE THAT
THOSE OUT [inaudible] SIX THE
SYSTEM IN ORDER TO ANSWER.
THE CALL AGAIN YEAH.
ITEM FOUR SB FORTY NINE BY
SKINNER TO PASS REFER TO
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTERS FIVE TO ONE WITH
THE TRAVELING AYE AND THE VICE
CHAIR.
NOT VOTING ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHOW I MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO MURATSUCHI.
RIGHT TO GI STONE. SEVEN TO
SEVENTY TWO THAT THOSE OUT.
ITEM SIX SB ONE SIXTY EIGHT Y.
KASKI DO PASS AS AMENDED.
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WE NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND --
LOCAL PLEASED TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN [inaudible]
GARCIA.
THERE ARE LIMON.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
AT THE SNOW MCCARTY.
CARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELINDA'S NO
MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI EYES STONE
[inaudible] SIX TWO SIXTY TWO
THAT GOES OUT. TO OPEN FOR THE
SYSTEM.
I DON'T SEVEN SB TWO WENTY SIX
BY NIELSEN TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFER TO WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE.
KERN VOTE SIX TO ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
I ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I MURATSUCHI ROTH TO GI.
EIGHT ZERO EIGHT ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT. NINE ZERO NINE ZERO I
EVEN MORE.
AN INMATE SB TWO FIFTY THREE BY
DODD TO PASS REFER TO
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE SIX ZERO WITH THE CHAIR AND
THE VICE CHAIR OF OWNING I
MEMBERS ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ AYE MURATSUCHI.
RED TO GI. TEN ZERO I DON'T NINE
SB FIVE THIRTY FIVE MORE LOCK.
TO PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE SEVEN ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHOW I EGGMAN.
BROUGHT TO TREAT ROUTE TO GI
STONE [inaudible]
SO NO. NINETY NINE ONE NINE ONE
AYE PHYLLIS OUT.
ITEM ELEVEN SB SIX THIRTEEN
MEMBER STERN DO PASSES AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE THREE TO THREE BUT
THE CHAIR VOTING I AND THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO ABSENT MEMBERS
CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I WROTE TO TREAT.
MURATSUCHI AYE STONE
[inaudible]
SO. NINE SEVEN THREE SEVEN THREE
THAT THOSE OUT.
ITEM THIRTEEN SB SIX SIXTY SEVEN
HUESO TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE IS.
SEVEN TO ZERO BUT THE CHAIR AND
THE VICE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS THE MON.
Là MON I MATHIS.
AT THIS AYE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
AYE MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN
ZERO MISS OUT.
THIS CALL THE ROLL FOR ANY OTHER
ABSENT MEMBERS THIS IS THE
SECOND COMING BACK.
YEAH.
STILL THERE YEAH ALRIGHT LET'S
CALL THE ROLL ANYWAY.
FOR THOSE OF ANY MEMBERS MISSED
SO THEY CAN LEAVE.
I TO ONE AJ ARE TEN REYES BE
ADOPTED -- VOTERS FIVE TO ONE
WITH THE CHORE VOTING I AND THE
VICE YOU'RE NOT VOTING ABSENT
MEMBERS EGGMAN.
WROTE TO CHOOSE MURATSUCHI EYES
STONE.
STONE I SEVEN ONE I DO THREE SB
FORTY THREE BY ALAN TO PASS
REFER TO REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO
THREE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
ABSENT MEMBERS STONE
[inaudible]
STONE I EIGHT THREE ONE IS OUT.
ITEM FOR SB FORTY NINE BY
SKINNER DO PASS REFER TO
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE SEVENTY TWO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I AND THE VICE
CHAIR NOT VOTING.
ABSENT MEMBERS STONE.
STONE I EIGHT TO ITEM FIVE SB
ONE THIRTY BY GALGIANI DO PASSES
AMENDED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR AND THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS
EGGMAN.
ROUTE TO G..
BROUGHT TO GI STONE.
SO. NINE TEN ZERO I DON'T SIX SB
ONE SIXTY EIGHT AYE KASKI DO
PASSES SOME MENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. FOR
ABOUT SIX TO TO WHAT THE CHAIR
VOTING I AM THE VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING.
AS A MEMBER STONE.
STONE I SEVEN TWO ITEM SEVEN SB
TWO TWENTY SIX NIELSEN TO PASS
AS AMENDED REFER TO WATER PARKS
AND WILDLIFE -- VOTE.
NINE TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR AND
THE VICE CHAIR MONNING AYE
ABSENT MEMBERS EGGMAN.
STONE.
STONE I TEN ZERO ITEM EIGHT SB
TWO FIFTY THREE DOT DO PASSED
REFERRED AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE TEND.
TO ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS STONE.
STONE I ELEVEN ZERO ITEM NINE SB
NINE FIVE THIRTY FIVE BY MORE
LOCK.
DO PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE.
NINETY ONE WITH THE CHAIR AND
THE VICE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS EGGMAN.
THE LORD IN HERE FOR ANYWAY.
WE'RE AT THE RESTAURANT -- YEAH
WELL WAY FRAGMENT ON THAT ONE SO
MANY BOOKS WHICH I GOT.
SO YEAH OKAY.
YEAH YOU'RE GOOD.
THANK YOU -- WHY DON'T WE WAIT A
MINUTE TO SEE WHAT THEY SAY
[inaudible]
SELECT.
OKAY WE ARE ADJOURNED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU